e
e e
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
five bills that we have scheduled for
public hearings today uh but before we
get to those I would ask you to please
join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance right here you
can't I pledge aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you everyone
okay the first the first bill scheduled
to be heard this morning is a host Bill
51 and to introduce it I would recognize
the prime sponsor representative Wendy
Thomas representative Thomas welcome
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I so look forward to the
national holiday that is called cannabis
day in New
Hampshire um I am here for the record I
am Wendy Thomas and I represent the town
of marac I'm here to introduce House
Bill 51 which is an act relative to hemp
derived cannabinoids and the and the
definition of cannabis and therapeutic
cannabis essentially this bill would
allow atcs to buy third-party hemp
products containing non-intoxicating
cannabinoids to use in their products
the way the law is currently written an
ATC must make products from what they
grow by allowing the purchase of
thirdparty
products it can cut down on expenses
which could then be passed on to the
patients many therapeutic cannabis
patients actively seek out products that
are higher in CBD and other non-
intoxicating cannabinoids as a way to
manage their
symptoms House Bill 51 addresses the
need for therapeutic dispensaries to
access a broader range of cannabis
derived products that can then be used
to support Medical Treatments while also
uring regulatory oversight and safety by
expanding the definition of cannabis to
include non intoxicating cannabinoids
such as CBD and other hemp derived uh
compounds the bill provides alternative
treatment centers the opportunity to
incorporate a wider variety of
therapeutic products this is particular
beneficial particularly beneficial for
patients seeking specific cannabinoids
that may be less likely to cause
psychoactive effects but still provide
relief from conditions like chronic pain
anxiety or
seizures this bill ensures that these
hemp derived cannabinoids and any
cannabis concentrates or infused
products manufactured from them undergo
thorough testing for contaminants and
cannabinoid
profiles this helps maintain high
standards for patient safety and product
consistency additionally the Prov Vision
prohibiting the use of hemp derived
products containing TC over
0.3% ensures that these therapeutic
products remain non intoxicating
aligning with the therapeutic use of the
dispensaries overall this legislation
allows dispensaries to offer a more
diverse range of products ultimately
improving patient access to the most
appropriate and effective treatments it
strikes a balance between expanding
therapeutic options and maintaining
strict regulatory control to safeguard
public health and the and the Integrity
of the medical cannabis program thank
you and I will take any questions thank
you any questions for representative
Thomas represent uh represent Paz uh
sorry I'm a little bit slow this morning
you mentioned cannabis day was it a joke
or is it an actual thing cannabis day oh
it's a joke um
it is not an actual thing although I
kind of wish it were but no no it's a
joke because you'll be seeing me all day
long you this is the day they schedule
cannabis
bills any other questions yes
representative
Lucas thank you Mr chair I just have a
couple of questions that are more
semantic in nature
um removing
seeds from the text why is that
necessary because the um federal
government has declared that seeds are
not cannabis because they have 0 point
they don't have enough THC in them so
they're sort of agnostic so seeds don't
really fall under that definition so
it's not possibly become intoxicated you
can't take seeds and get
intoxicated is is that the question
right and and any manner correct correct
thank
you another question just representative
McGrath how would the testing for
contaminants work oh everything um that
goes into um a dispensary from a third
party would be tested at a state lab um
and they have protocol for that right
now and then everything that is created
every product created from that third
party even though it was Prior test or
tested priorly um it would be retested
by the state lab there's a very um a um
strict uh process that's
followed and um so the person or the
company I'm sorry go ahead followup I
wasn't going to say it so I just say
followup yeah you just request to follow
up if you want have another question you
can do
this and the company that's buying it
pays for the testing oh yeah yeah yep
absolutely other questions
oh yes representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman would you believe that I
strongly support this
legislation uh because it distinguishes
between recreational use of marijuana
and medical use and we hear a lot of
negativity about marijuana
uh recreationally and we don't hear so
much about the medical use uh so I think
that this is very important
legislation um thank you representative
and I would absolutely believe um that
you believe that um and just um in so
for the record also I should have put it
out first I am a therapeutic cannabis
patient I use cannabis on a daily basis
for uh pain control and for cancer
related Sy symptoms um you will never
see me intoxicated because that's not
why I use cannabis I use it in
microdoses and it controls my pain it
controls my symptoms so that I can get
to work and show up and do things like
this um so I believe that's an
incredibly important distinction we are
not talking about adult use here we are
talking about therapeutic use for
patients thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry
knar Thank you Mr chair um and actually
I I passed around the testimony for all
of the bills that we have that affect
the therapeutic cannabis program uh
earlier but I also passed around a
little fact sheet we put this together
because we have a show and tell table
downstairs at lunchtime no no free
samples though um but that we have a
little handout that's a little more
abbreviated from this but I realized
again there's such a turnover that many
people may not know much about this
program you know because it came in in
2013 statutorily and then was effective
in 2016 so the point is this gives you
some issues for example the quality
testing everything gets tested and the
point of this bill is that it will be
things will be test tested if they come
from outside as well I serve uh well
first I was a state rep for six years I
serve as the chair of the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board which
was instituted in 2019 uh and
statutorily charged with medical
oversight of a therapeutic cannabus
program and it's composed of uh the D
the DHHS medical director a therapedic
cannabis patient a representative of an
ATC and 10 different medical providers
in different
Specialties
um the uh the issue is that we do
support this uh Bill we voted to do so
because cannabis is a complex herb has
over 70 cannabinoids and over 450
chemical constituents the most common
one we all think about is THC that's the
intoxicating one but there are many non-
intoxicating canabo as well the one the
most commonly known as CBD but there's
other variations as well and they all
have different therapeutic benefits sort
of the mix of these plus the things that
give the smell which is called the tpin
those together have unique effects for
each individual an herb is different
than you go to the drugstore you get
your linil it's one molecule with a
bunch of carriers that's it these are uh
kind of fashioned together to give
different effects and the point is that
CBD can be very helpful for patients or
they non-
intoxicating uh canabo can be very
helpful and uh as represented Thomas
said the goal in therapeutic cannabis is
to get a therapeutic effect without the
troubling side effect of euphoria
because if you're an 80-year-old who's
got pain and it's 2 in the morning get
up to go pee you don't need to be stoned
it's just not going to work so the
bottom line is we don't want Euphoria we
don't want sedation so any case we need
these other um non- intoxicating canono
but because of the uh significant costs
and growing that are imposed Upon Our at
seas because of the degree of security
and indoor growth facilities and so on
and so forth um that's all in place
because of the intoxicating nature of
THC but these non intoxicating
intoxicating cannaboids don't need to be
that way and hemp is uh is legally is
federally legal as long as the
concentration of THC within the hemp is
less than. 3% and that can just be grown
out in a field without all these
requirements so it's a lot cheaper to
produce and it's a good source of CBD
and other non- intoxicating cannabinoids
and we we need those to be able to mix
with the THC to make the cannabis
infused products and the oils and so on
and so forth that are sold by the atc's
because again the different effects are
needed for different people so the hemp
since it can be growing much more
economically will allow us I'll get I'll
wrap up allow us I was doing little
explanation stuff that took some time uh
they will allow us to to be able to then
get that more cheaply will lower costs
and that will allow the atcs to have
lower cost products and that's important
to our patients because cost is a very
uh important barrier for many of our
patients so given the great need for CBD
Rich products we think this is
beneficial we voted 7 to zero to support
this bill um I'd be glad to take any
questions and again I want to invite you
to just drop by our table at lunchtime
if you wish to learn a little bit more
thanks and and that uh thing at
lunchtime it at 12 to1 12 to2 or I'm
sorry what what what is the exact
schedule of the thing oh um I've got
some people that are going to be setting
it up at about
11:30 and we knock off about 1:15 or so
whenever the cafeteria start to get
empty and I'll I'll hightail it down
there as soon as we finish the bills so
that I can be down there as well so
basically 12 to1 but padded on each end
okay great any
questions say no questions
okay wow that was easy
H also sign also signed up to speak is
Michael Holt from the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human
Services thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Michael Holt
I'm the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program uh with the Department
of Health and Human Services I've been
working with this program since its
Inception in
um the um previous speakers presented
the bill I don't have too much to add um
except that the department does support
this bill um Department believes that um
the bill will result in increased
product options for uh patients that
contain these non- intoxic
cannabinoids um and uh also lower prices
uh for these products as compared to
what would be charged if the ATC uh were
to produce these cannabinoids on their
own um as stated the bill requires all
externally source canabo to be uh tested
before they're put into a product and
those products tested afterwards
essentially double testing for uh this
this third party um uh these third party
canabo um and lastly the administrative
resources for uh the department you know
rulemaking and inspections um and
whatnot basically to enforce compliance
with the law U can be absorbed within
our budget um so this is we have no
issues with the with the with the bill
we support the bill we believe it will
help uh patients um have lower cost uh
prices on a greater array of therapeutic
products um I'm happy to answer
questions about the program about this
bill um and I'll be here all day as well
great any
questions representative
McGrath I thank you
um is the hemp product have all of the
ingredients
that you're looking for for your
patients or is it a do they combine it
with
other cannabis products uh it would be
thank you it would be it would be a
mixture um I believe there's a speaker
from the ATC um coming after me he might
be able to speak more to the product
offerings um my understanding is that um
the the the hemp produces various
cannaboids like CBD which is canabidol
CBG CBN um and these are in concentrated
forms and so the the goal would be for
the ATC to produce um a variety of
products that contain greater levels of
them so a common product would be a
ratio product that mixes an equal amount
of THC and CBD or a 20 to1 20% you know
20 uh ratio of uh you know 20 times CBD
versus one part uh therapeutic cannabis
so there's a whole range of um of
options um that the atcs could make um
the point here is that the nontoxin
cannaboids can be sourced more cheaply
uh than if they were to produce it on
their own thus those cost savings would
be passed on to patients for these
particular products does that answer
your
question
followup uh yes so I I guess the
question was if hemp is so much cheaper
can can it all be sourced from
hemp no because hemp by definition and
what makes it legal is that it has under
3%
THC and THC is an important therapeutic
component uh as as
well representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and am I
correct in understanding that the issue
here is because of the security
that we require of the growth centers
and because we currently require the
atcs to grow everything that they sell
and they cannot Source it anywhere
else that because of the limited grow
space
available in very controlled
settings
um it's
impossible even to have the space let
alone uh Do It um economically feasibly
to have the widest range of products
available for patients who need
different arrays and who need their
products tailored very carefully to
their own specific
needs representative Weber you're
hitting on a lot of the issues uh and a
lot of the components of the program and
the regulations around uh atcs um again
representative of the ATC will be uh
speaking uh next and he can perhaps
answer more clearly but um but yes um
the atcs currently grow CBD Rich strains
of cannabis um but they can tell you
that those plants are not as productive
say so they're not getting as much CBD
out of um the plants as uh a t THC Rich
plant for instance and so because of the
limited grow space that they have and
the and the cost for operating you know
each grow room um there the the the cost
incentive of of growing and producing as
much CBD uh that patients might want is
is is a challenge um and so this would
this again this would allow uh the atcs
to Source these nontoxin cannabinoids
and not grow them and not use their
precious you know grow spacee um to grow
the plants that produce um these high
levels of uh nontoxin cannabinoid
thank you representative kall thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so following on uh
representative McGrath's question um
this committee heard uh substantial
concerns last year uh with respect to
some of the synthetic cannaboids so U
Delta 8 Delta 9 variants my
understanding is that this bill would do
nothing to allow the introduction of
those into uh the medical cannabis um
dispensaries essentially uh this would
this this would continue to protect
patients against the introduction of
synthetic um synthetic cannaboids into
into what they're using correct that is
that that is correct um hemp derived
cannabinoids that contain THC are
prohibited under state law uh even
though they are widely available um in
uh smoke shops gas stations and whatnot
this is a this is a separate um effort
to allow hemp derived cannabinoids
without THC uh to be used by the
atc's other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Sue
hamala from Sam New Hampshire
remind us what Sam stands for yes sir um
smart approaches to marijuana okay so
I'm Sue hola um the New Hampshire
chairwoman of uh smart approaches to
marijuana which is a national drug abuse
prevention organization um I wanted to
highlight there are three important
issues to consider when discussing uh HB
51 number one the federal guidance
listed in the 2018 farm bill in the 2022
deac seed letter the non-standard
federal and state definition of hemp
marijuana and cannabis and New
Hampshire's lack of an a USDA approved
hemp plan the agriculture Improvement
act also called the farm bill of 2018
authorized the production of hemp
classified hemp as a regul regulated
commodity and had a provision to remove
hemp and hemp seeds from the DEA admin
uh DEA list of controlled
substances in 2022 the daa released a
letter stating that the seeds containing
less than .3% THC meet the definition of
hemp and are not considered control
substance under federal law however
there's still a legal issue require uh
regarding the source rule which is a
legal theory used to establish the
legality of cannabis material based off
its source it is understood that if the
material comes from hemp it is legal but
if it comes from marijuana even if the
material contains less than. 3% THC it
is illegal according to Legal analysts
The Source role became less applicable
with regard to seed legality of hemp
cultivation after the 2018 Farm Bill
however the source role remains in
effect with regard to the context of
hemp cultivation and processing of
products intended for human consumption
which HB 51 is intended for in addition
the 2022 seed letter does not exempt
States from having the uh having a chain
of title for the hemp and hemp material
they produce and or
handle more importantly federal law
still use the terms hemp marijuana in US
code langu in US code language cannabis
is the only is only referred to as a
classification of the plant New
Hampshire uses the term cannabis which
is the similar to the term marijuana
under federal law the 2022 daac letter
clarifies the definition of a hemp seed
by using terms dis similar to Federal
definitions and using the de seed letter
um on top of that uh New Hampshire's
legal flame framework gets a little bit
confusing on another important note many
states have a USDA approved state plan
to regulate the processing of hemp and
the production of finished products to
include the products intended for human
consumption these plans also outline the
states hemp sourcing policies to ensure
the source rule is legally followed
currently New Hampshire does not have a
USDA approved state plan for hemp
production it only has a USDA hemp
producer license so it stand New
Hampshire's recommendation that the New
Hampshire consider aligning their
definitions for hemp and marijuana to
align with Federal uh us code so that
Federal guidance can be implemented with
maximum Clarity and also be more prudent
to outline New Hampshire's hemp
production in a USDA approved plan which
clearly out outlines our source role
procedures before before moving forward
with other actions okay thank you
representative
Weber thank you and thank you for taking
my question so uh with all of that being
said what and and I understand your your
position on what would be helpful if we
did it but it's not the bill in front of
us what is your position on the bill in
front of us that at this time it would
that do not go forward do not press
ahead with this so you're opposed to the
bill at this time I am opposed to the
Bill thank
you other questions
seeing none okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Matt
Simon with green leaf
cannabis good morning good morning Mr
chairman honorable committee good to see
some new faces and many Amar faces for
the record Matt Simon I work for granite
Leaf cannabis we one of the three
companies that's licensed to operate
alternative treatment centers in New
Hampshire we have a grow facility in
Peterborough and two dispensaries one in
marac one in
Chichester um most of what I was going
to say has already been said very well
uh to partially answer your question
representative McGrath we currently
offer a number of products that are
either just CBD products or are as was
previously mentioned CBD ratio products
so for example a fruit chew we don't
call them gummies because to some people
that sounds like candy so they're called
Fruit Chews if you look at our menu you
can find fruit shoes that contain THC
you can find fruit shoes that contain
just CBD you can find fruit shoes that
contain CBD and THC in a one:1 ratio we
also offer ures that include THC in
ratio with CBD and other cannabinoids
one of our tinctures includes CBD and
CBG which is
cannabol uh basically for all the time
that I worked on this issue uh it was
understood incorrectly that the main
ingredient in cannabis is THC and that's
the active ingredient it turns out there
are over a 100
canabo uh that have shown great
potential in research Arch and in the
patient population so as you know we
have a therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board a number of providers on
that board specifically are very
interested in seeing the atcs offer more
CBD and CBD ratio products uh so much of
the research that's been happening
that's very promising is not Research
into just the effects of THC it's
Research into how people are responding
to various canabo uh so thanks to the
Federal legalization of hemp which has
created a lot of complications the feds
have not bothered to regulate hemp so
it's Fallen to the states and most H
markets are not well regulated so the
way this bill is written uh atc's could
purchase CBD oil for example in bulk we
would have to send it to our independent
lab that tests all of our other cannabis
products they would have to certify that
that oil is what it that it's free from
impurities and it is what it says it is
and we could then use that oil to make
products like the tinctures and the
fruit shoes that I've just mentioned so
we do currently grow CBD in house uh
that's
been I'd hate to calculate the expense
of doing it indoors under high-intensity
lighting versus what's happening uh
thousands of hemp producers in the
United States are growing fields of hemp
and producing these
products we're trying to bridge the gap
of the regulation by buying these
products that may or may not have been
properly properly regulated we're going
to get them lab tested and then we're
going to have the products we make from
them tested before we can sell them to
patients so please support the bill
happy to answer any questions thank you
representative
Weber am I correct in understanding that
because of the rigorous testing that you
must undergo both at purchase and once
the product is
formulated that this is far more
controlled and far more in the best
interest of patients than the things you
can buy in the local gas station which
are not regulated or are regulated but
certainly not as subject subject to as
rigorous testing yeah thank you for the
question representative wether there are
a lot of hemp derived products available
some in gas stations I hope that's not
happening as much because that is
illegal in New Hampshire uh but
certainly online and people are finding
these products patients are finding
these products and they're buying these
products and some of them are working
great and we just don't know what's in
them unless somebody's actually tested
them and for New Hampshire patients
having access to a regulated source of
of
cannabinoids therapeutic cannabis should
be about more than just THC and this
bill would help us realize
that thank you other question questions
representative
McGrath I oh thank you just to clarify I
think rep Thomas mentioned it being
tested in State Labs and you had just
said independent Labs is that the same
lab it is not a state run lab it is a
state licensed independent lab that
tests all therapeutic cannabis produced
and sold by
atc's other questions
seeing none okay thank
you also signed up to speak is J Matthew
judge from tascal I believe it
is did I pronounce the name of the
company correctly
or thank you
turn on your mic there you go thank you
to the chair and committee for letting
me testify today um I am a registered
agent of tascal Wellness um we are in
support of this bill for the reasons
already stated but we wanted to come
today and support it um in person
because of what we think of the
importance of this bill for patients uh
in New Hampshire so with that I'll take
any questions when you said you only
needed a minute you were
serious any questions
okay I'm saying none thank you
sir uh no one else has signed up to
speak does anyone else wish to speak on
this
bill seeing no one I am going to close
the public hearing on HB 51 uh the next
bill is we will be considering is HB 53
it's not scheduled until 10:15 so we'll
be in recess until then
that
e
e e
representative Thomas and honorable
Jerry kerk when you do background
information it's very helpful for us if
you tell us who it's coming
from uh we always prefer to identify our
sources so we
know okay no we've got it now but but
it's helpful for me and it's much more
helpful for the clerk who is dealing
with enormous amounts of paper
okay I'd like to reconvene uh and open
the hearing on House Bill 53 and
recognize representative Wendy Tomas
once once again she's a busy lady
today not the last time you're going to
be seeing
me um uh for the record I am Wendy
Thomas and I represent the town of marac
I'm here to introduce House Bill 53
which is an act permitting qualifying
patients and designated caregivers to
cultivate cannabis for therapeutic use I
have passed out two documents uh one is
some background on the Cannabis home
cultivation laws in New England and the
second one is the home cultivation of
therapeutic cannabis legislative history
yeah you're welcome done with that um uh
this is not the first rodeo for this
bill similar bills have been passed by
the house in 2021 2023 and
2024 so why do we need this bill first
of all cost cannabis is not covered by
insurance if you are a patient who uses
a lot to keep your symptoms under
control it can be expensive and remember
this is a vulnerable population many of
us are unable to hold jobs house bills
uh 53 helps lowincome immobile or
homebound patients who need medical
cannabis be able to grow their own
medicine or to get help doing
so dispensary locations there are seven
dispensaries in all of New Hampshire not
all patients have cars or an affordable
way to get to them just to put that into
perspective we have five pharmacies in
my town of
miramac strains everyone reacts
differently to cannabis strains what may
work for one patient may not be as
effective as effective for another
sometimes the strain that works best for
you might be discontinued growing that
would be a good option the New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis program began in
2013 it is 12 years old since it began
we have learned a lot about the program
and patient needs dispensaries have been
added along the way with more
qualifications to get into the program
and the program has been modified to
better suit patients
needs since 2009 the New Hampshire house
has consistently supported bills
allowing patients with qualifying
medical conditions and their caregivers
to cultivate a limited supply of
cannabis in 2012 and 2019 the Senate
agreed advancing home legislation to the
governor's desk both bills were vetoed
and the override efforts fell short in
the senate in 2020 the Senate passed a
homow bill and a Voice vote but the
outbreak of covid-19 prevented it from
being considered in the house what this
bill does HB 53 allows New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis patients or care G
givers to grow their own cannabis plants
at their place of residence within guard
rails set forward by this bill patients
are still Bound by the guidelines of the
program as identified when you submit or
renew your
application if grown outside the plants
cannot be viewed from another private
property it would allow New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis patients to have
and grow Three Mature which are
flowering plants three immature or
non-flowering plants and 12 seedlings
which are identified at 6 in or less
patients can grow the plants from seeds
and some of the dispensaries have said
that they would be willing and able to
provide
seedlings the plants must be kept in a
locked and secured location that is
reported to the state the patient must
ensure that the plants are secured from
unauthorized access patients would have
access to State Labs for testing or
independent Labs as well for testing of
cannabinoids and possible contamination
most probably mold
what this bill does not do this bill
does not mean that every therapeutic
cannabis patient will start growing
plants some patients will try and
realize it's too much work and will stop
some patients will be interested and
will simply gather information on how to
grow cannabis plants and some people uh
some patients will simply say I'd rather
buy the flower hp53 does not create
dealers or suppliers the therapeutic
cannabis program is
self-regulating to be in the program you
must sign a contract that stipulates
limitations on how much cannabis we can
have where we can keep it and where we
can use it we know that if we disregard
these conditions we can be kicked out of
the program or we will be pen penalized
at a higher rate than others no patient
is going to risk that again this is not
Recreation this is a medical program for
very sick patients it does not create
hidden stashes of cannabis growth
locations must be reported to the
state so what's happening in some of the
other states in Connecticut you're
allowed up to Three Mature plants and
three immature plants in Maine you're
allowed up to six flowering plants 12
immature plants and unlimited seedlings
in Massachusetts you can have six plants
per person or patient no more than 12 in
Rhode Island up to 12 mat M plants and
12 immature plants per patient in
Vermont up to two mature plants and
seven immature plants per patient so who
supports this bill this has always been
a bipartisan bill that continually
passes the house the dispensary support
homow and we are ready to roll out
classes on how to grow and may even
offer some equipment needed to grow the
therapeutic cannabis board voted
unanimously to support this bill it is
seen as economical way to support
therapeutic cannabis patients in summary
the New Hampshire therapeutic program
has been alive and well since 2013 and
is only getting stronger as we listen to
patients needs HB 53 is a compassionate
Humane bill that also encourages
business growth it's time to let
patients take control of their health
and wallets by allowing for home growth
in the therapeutic program thank you and
I'll take questions representative Weber
thank you so much and thank you for your
thorough explanation and walking us
through the bill are there any language
changes in this bill from the way the
house uh passed it in
2024 yes and no and and thank you for
reminding me the no is that the the the
text of the bill Remains the Same um the
yes is that page four line 27 has the
wrong date it's a drafting error it
should be 2024 2025 so that's why the
yes and no it is the same text however
that date needs to be changed and could
you give me that line number again
please yes it's page 4 line 27 2005 okay
so other other than the date changes the
this is the exact same wording that was
introduced twice last term so it should
say 2025 and we should perhaps obtain an
an amend an amendment for one date yes
unfortunately yes thank you so much well
thank you for the question and for
reminding me to say
that representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for your
work uh one of the concerns I think
about this legislation which again I
strongly
support
is how you prevent the grower from
selling uh outside of their own use my
understanding is that this is for their
own use only correct and but what you
mentioned briefly some measures to
prevent them from selling could you
expand on that
um I believe um Michael Hol will be
testifying after me and he can go into
more detail but when you enter the
therapeutic cannabis program you have to
sign essentially a contract that says
you will not sell and that you will
follow the guidelines um right now in
the Cannabis program uh there are higher
penalties for therap which I don't think
is fair but that's another discussion um
for selling so if somebody on the street
sold and was arrested they would have
one penalty if somebody is in the
program and sold they would have a
higher penalty um and if you uh sell you
are disqualified from the program I mean
you could be disqualified from the
program which is most of the patients if
not all of the patients um respect the
program and and want it to continue so
that's a high risk and I I think it's
you know essentially
self-regulating thank you other
questions representative Maser and then
representative
McGrath yes thank thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here today you so I
having never grown cannabis myself or
even been around a cannabis plant this
may be a a weird question but is there
an a stench or an odor that comes in the
growth of these plants that could like
let's say someone grows it in an
apartment building could that affect
other people I mean it it's a plant so
just like a tomato plant has a smell to
it again you're limited in the amount of
plant
so it's it's not you're not going to
walk into an apartment building and say
oh my God somebody's growing cannabis
here it's it's a mild um a mild smell
just like any other plant um
and um you have to force the the flow
the bud um but you don't get to the
flowering so you're not going to have
even a perfume or anything like that and
it doesn't smell it's an organic smell
it's it's like smelling hay or something
like that you're not going to get the
smell that you smell when somebody
smokes
it representative McGrath and then
representative
Nagel hi thank you so I'm a little
confused in Maine it says a caregiver
may serve up to five patients is the
grower the people have to be in the same
house or can somebody be growing it for
patients in different locations and did
that will that be the same in this bill
so in New Hampshire you're allowed um to
have caregivers and again Michael Hulk
can can uh can uh talk about that as
well um in Maine uh you can you it's
it's like a hub for somebody who can't
grow you you have a career Giver who
grows for you and so they provide the
the material for those five patients
so so they're sort of the the manager of
the cannabis for those patients if that
makes any
sense representative nichel I think that
this is a a question of order am I
allowed to ask the question that
representative misser
asked you mean the same question she
asked yeah allowed to answer it for her
oh sure if you have in insight into the
issue sure well I've toured a number of
cultivation centers and it smells just
like citrus it's like a lot of the
bathroom sprays people use and it's
actually quite nice it's not like the
smoke smell you get it's nothing like
that it's actually a lovely smell it it
really is I was pleasantly surprised
yeah okay um any other
questions yes representative Palmer I
mean representative Mel I'm
sorry turn on your mic microphone sorry
thank you for taking my question so um
you're mentioning the different states
here that have
um uh various permit permit levels for
this can you talk to us a little bit
about the the regulations and how
they're handling it by each
state I'm not sure I'm the best person
to answer that um I focus on the New
Hampshire um okay so I mean I'm just
looking at it and it says Maine has some
regulations Massachusetts I think it's
different uh Rhode Island Vermont all of
them have it and I was just wondering
I I'm not sure I'm the person to answer
that I'm sorry thank
you representative
merer thank you um so you said you
mentioned they have a card um that
they're given does that enter Then enter
them into a registry that the state
police can randomly show up and check
then yes it does oh I'm seeing heads
shaking back there oh okay that's I I
was under the Imp question that there
was a well okay somebody behind me will
will answer that question better than me
because apparently I don't have the
right answer okay other questions yes
representative Woods oh thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question uh
you mentioned testing and I'm just
scanning here uh what is the role of you
are the Growers required to have their
product tested or did I hear you say
they just have they can test it and have
availability to other facilities to get
that accomplished they have the option
okay it is not required and
representative your your bandage is
coming a little loose on your head oh my
head will fall off
well you're
good thank you uh representative
Lucas thank you Mr chair just a question
about the um growing phase of plants and
what's changed from seed
to immature cannabis that's line
30 on page
five um my question is uh from by
changing from seedlings to immature
cannabis does that
increase the amount of therapeutic
cannabis permitted and if there's an
excess Beyond what's
permitted what happens to that
excess uh so I'm just looking at so
um you're line 30 is referring to um the
atcs with aiding mature um cannabis
plants yes so
um I'm not sure I have the answer to
that question either and so I'm going to
different refer to someone from the
ATC um but a patient would never have 0
plants MH I mean this is the ATC they're
talking about not a patient yeah I'm
sorry I jumped ahead so um and and
that's fine but um you know uh the the
patient is allowed to have uh Three
Mature plants
so you're not going to get a you're
going to get a significant amount of
cannabis but you're not going to get you
know buckets and buckets and buckets of
cannabis buds because you you the the
part that most people are interested in
is the actual bud that's where the THC
crystals are so it's not the plant
itself it's the buds and some plants Bud
more than other
plants other
questions I I actually have a question
representative Thomas sure and this is I
know speculative and and probably
premature definitely premature but I in
looking at the home cultivation of
therapeutic cannabis legislative history
stream uh it has had you know some
success on the legislative branch but it
seems like every time it makes it to the
Conor office it's been regardless of
party not received well um given
Governor aot's comments about cannabis
and I I know she's mainly focused on
recreational and her law enforcement
background do you have any insight as to
what she might do have there been any
conversations with with her at all do
you know I have not had any
conversations however I remain an
eternal optimist and I I I know that she
has um telegraphed that she is against
adult use just blanket against adult use
once again this is not adult use this is
therapeutic the majority of of uh people
in New Hampshire um uh support uh adult
use and so I'm hoping that she might see
a bill like this as a nod to the people
who support cannabis but that it would
help therapeutic patients and that is
purely speculative sure now I understand
um she hasn't been there that long and
uh the bill isn't actually there yet
again I my I'm
only prompted to ask the question
because I noticed Governor Lynch and
Governor Hassen were loath to support it
in fact weo did so which is one of the
reasons I keep coming back and I keep
putting bills for forward like this
because there's so much misinformation
about cannabis specifically therapeutic
cannabis people think cannabis in
general is bad bad bad it's a drug you
know um uh it's got a it's got a history
um of being portrayed as you know the
devil's weed and that kind of stuff I
keep coming forward and keep uh talking
to people about therapeutic cannabis
because it changes lives this is a uh a
medication it's it's a true
medication that when it is used
therapeutically can make all the
difference and um I I've said it in
previous testimonies I'll repeat it now
when I started the program I was on a
pain contract with opioids and I was
given 120 tablets a month to control my
pain um everybody knows that that's not
a good situation it's lifelong it
doesn't change the symptoms it doesn't
change the situation and you only get
more used to it and then you require
more and more and more when I started
the program I stopped the opioids I
simply didn't need them
anymore so it's a Humane bill it's an
economic bill it helps patients who
can't afford their medication it's just
something and if it doesn't pass I'll be
back again promoting it okay thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry
kerk thank you very much Mr chair and uh
the testimony I passed around in that
little packet of things you have on your
desk from earlier for the record Jerry
nerk uh I'm the chair of the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board and
I've already told you what it is I do
want to actually Echo something that has
been said uh just a moment ago if we
look at our most recent annual data
report 72% of our patients are certified
for pain that's really the one the some
of the best data for its utility is in
the treatment of pain and that's where
uh we have the majority of our patients
the great majority of Ages 50 to 60
looking around the average their meeting
age in this group you know that as you
get a little older a lot of things hurt
and some of them you know you just do
norm and they go away but some things
become really quite troubling for your
life
and um I'd like to Echo also what
representative Thomas said a lot of
patients are able to diminish the
medications they take often particularly
been able to avoid opioids entirely and
that's really quite beneficial because
they don't have the exposure and
therefore the risk for opioid disuse
disorder tcob does support this bill
it's the same as some bills in the past
has been pointed out and we support it
because it allow home cultivation by
therapeutic cannabis patients and
designated caregivers to help them with
affordability accessibility and
availability of specific strains just to
clarify too caregivers in this state
mean somebody who basically handles the
cannabis for somebody let's say you're
80 years old uh you don't drive your
eyes are bad and your closest uh
dispensary is an hour away well somebody
can go pick that up for you and bring it
back and the reason we have they're your
caregiver they're designated therefore
they will not be charged with possession
when they're doing that U on your behalf
uh they're not this is not a setting
where we have caregivers growing for
other people people and this is uh not
the point of this bill but our
caregivers just help patients obtain it
in any case um we had a listening
session about three years ago with our
patients and uh we got a lot of feedback
and the most common concerns were the
affordability of the products the
accessibility of the atcs and the
availability of specific
strains uh which may not be available
from their nearest ATC the specific
strain they might need to treat their
symptoms because as been pointed out
different strains have different effects
for different people and so that really
matters for treating their particular
illness so many patients thought that
home cultivation would help to solve
this again as was mentioned a lot of
people aren't going to do this um I'm a
big Gardener I have a big Greenhouse all
kinds of stuff but you know a lot of
people don't want to invest that kind of
time or they're in an apartment or they
they just don't have a place where they
could actually even grow it so this is
not going to be a lot of people but
they'll be some that might do it um at
the January 2023 meeting we reviewed the
initial bill of HB 431 and voted
unanimously to agree with it and we've
renewed our approval with each of these
subsequent bills again uh there were
some uh concerns in the past about you
know the the diminished knowledge about
canabo content to the home cultivation
uh cultiv ours and well that is true
again the uh they can't guarantee
exactly how it's going to grow but that
gives you a good chance for that uh I do
want to make one point up toight I've
spoken about what the TCM o stands for
as a group I'd like to speak for myself
just with one thing we did not go into
all of the weeds of this bill um because
we didn't want to worry about all that
detail we just support the concept but I
want to point out that there are robust
protections with respect to limitations
in the number of plants uh the
registration of cultivation sites that
have to be enclosed and locked and these
should make it safe secure and
controlled and satisfy the concerns of
law enforcement so we urge you to pass
hp53 to allow home cultivation to help
patients with affordability
accessibility and availability of
specific strains and I'd be glad to take
questions as well thank you
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question and I
think you already know the question I'm
going to ask but I don't remember you
will so
um you know I I support everything
you've said up to a point um I think
I've certified probably as many patients
for therapeutic cannabis as as
anybody um with that said I'm not aware
of any pharmaceutical that we allow
people to produce at home because of
reproducibility concerns risk benefit
ratios things like that um I appreciate
the
um the Protections in this bill and all
that but the reason why I don't support
it is because I just don't think you can
make a reproducible product at
home tell me can is there any way you
can tell me why I'm
wrong no uh but in essence though to
remember there's a couple of things
about it you're right it will not be uh
well actually let's back up a bit when
you get a generic medication remember
the the range for what has to be in that
is plus or minus 20 which means you
might get one batch one time and the
next batch May that only has 80% of what
it's supposed to have and the next one
could be 120% so that's not entirely
reproducible when you go by your you
know your over the-counter not over
counter your generic
theil so there's a lot of variability
there anyway but also with cannabis
there is no one set dose a person uh
doses the rule uses start low go slow
and gradually increase if they have a
new batch they would probably do the
same thing they would start with a very
small thing and say well that's not
giving me the effect I need and tweak it
up a little bit more till they get the
may say pain relief that they desire but
without too much sedation or Euphoria so
they given the dosing that we do which
is a little bit more individualized than
what we do when we're treating your
hypertension or something like that not
as much of a problem um lastly again is
that you you know a person can if they
really are quite sensitive or they're
trying a new batch and they're not
getting what they want they can submit
it for testing and find out precisely
what that cannaboid content is um it's
not not an exact science I would agree
but I would again point out that if we
get generic drugs they're not exact
either so
yeah other
questions representative
delus thank you Mr
chair representative um I'm forward
curious to know who who goes and checks
on the number of plants is it state is
it the providers
how how are these where are the checks
and balances that the physical you know
knock on the door go to someone's house
and say oh you've got five plants
there's in the bill I do not remember
that there was any kind of uh inspection
program at all but in the bill it is
also noted that if for example uh law
enforcement has questions or concerns
they can't just go knock on the door but
they can submit an affidavit uh to
confirm whether there is growth at that
place or whether that person is allowed
to grow
um and I think then once they've got the
affidavit and a search warrant they can
go and check so there that can be
checked if there's a suspicion that
somebody is growing a lot producing it
and they're selling it somewhere uh law
enforcement can follow up on
that
followup thank
you so is there any should we be
concerned about an FN on this I mean is
it just so slight that we wouldn't worry
about financial
burden for yeah since there's nothing in
the law that requires the
ATC sorry requires the program to go do
an inspection that that cost to be
minimal the the patient does have to uh
submit uh register that they're going to
be having a cultivation but that's a
pretty trivial uh
addition again we don't expect all that
many people are going to do it I mean a
lot of people are a lot happier to go
there buy their Tomatoes at the farm
Market than to go through all the
trouble of growing their
Tomatoes other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Michael
Holt from the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services you've
asked for four minutes three would be
better if you can do
it thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um I will be brief um happy to
answer some of the questions that went
around the table that were um couldn't
be answered earlier as well for the
record my name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services um House Bill
53 the department takes no position on
but I do want to be here um to um to
establish that we agree that this bill
will result in benefits to patients due
to increased access increase strain
availability and lower costs um and I
want to highlight some of the uh
safeguards and guard rails um uh that
are included in this bill the expressed
concerns about home cultivation are
usually focused on the increased
potential for diversion um considering
the regional access to cannabis by
adults here in New Hampshire we're
surrounded by legal states uh the lower
prices of recreational cannabis in other
states as compared to New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis and the extra
penalties for patients who divert the
risk of diversion has greatly diminished
since this law passed in 2013
um some of the safeguards included in
this bill include it allows only a very
small number of plants Three Mature
three
immature either the patient or the
caregiver can cultivate not
both if a caregiver cultivates the
caregiver can only have one patient not
the allowed five uh if they're if
they're not cultivating the cultivation
location must be at the person's
residence the cultivation location must
be reported to and registered with the
therapeutic cannabis program including
any changes to cultivation location the
location must be out of public view in a
locked and enclosed space with a size
limitation a landlord can prohibit home
cultivation representative Mazer if
there's concerns about odor um the
department is authorized to share the
registered cultivation location with
local and state law enforcement upon
receipt of a sworn affidavit that's a
lesser standard than a court
order um atcs are allowed by this bill
to sell seeds and seedlings to patients
they'll be expected to provide education
to patients on
cultivation uh the LI there are limits
about the number of uh seedlings that
can be sold which align with the maximum
number of plants and seedlings elsewhere
in the
law the one independent Testing Lab in
the state is permitted by this bill to
test samples from patients and
caregivers who grow their own this is
not required um but the this has
indicated their willingness uh and
interest in doing
so um and the department has the
authority to revoke a patient or
caregivers cultivation privilege for any
violation of law or rule um so to
summarize the department can
operationalize this legislation without
issue without fiscal impact um I'm happy
to take more questions but I'm happy to
answer some of the questions that were
already asked um we talked about
prevention of diversion um and that it's
it's it's not as nearly a risk as it was
in 2013 when the uh uh the law first
passed talked about odor
um there is we uh we have a state
registry representative um maer but it
is a confidential registry it's a
medical program state and local law
enforcement do have special access to it
to verify the validity of a card but
they must meet certain thresholds they
don't have direct access through their
Cruisers say um and we we feel those
calls on a regular basis um
the uh your question representative
Lucas about the uh the the is there is
there an excess cannabis produced at the
atcs um that section of law is uh is
being changed to align the terms mature
and immature um it is not changing the
amounts of cannabis being uh Allowed by
the atcs um but to answer your question
uh there's no market for cannabis to be
sold besides patients so there's no
incentive for the atcs to produce more
than what they can sell to patients um
the uh the caps in law have never been
exceeded not even close um in terms of
uh the the atc's current inventory we
require the atcs to have very strict
inventory controls including a seed to
sell software which uh which um tracks
all plants um all products Etc um and to
the question of who enforces the the it
uh the answer is is it is self enforced
um the penalties of being caught
producing more and losing your card are
are serious for a patient um and so uh
this bill does not contain any
provisions where law enforcement or the
state uh can access people's homes um
however as I mentioned there are
Provisions where we can uh relay that
information of a cultivate cultivation
location to local and state law
enforcement thank you for going over um
you've answer several questions that
people had and are there any other
questions from the committee You' been
very very compreh oh representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman one of the obvious things is
the distinction between recreational use
of marijuana and and medical
marijuana uh I think the general public
thinks of marijuana as
marijuana and that is the department
considering bring anything about
public um
information that would emphasize the
therapeutic use of
marijuana because
the the concern in the legislature I
think is the use of marijuana illegally
and
inappropriately and not so much the
support of that very important
uh therapeutic use of marijuana so it is
the department I know you're a onean
show uh but that is the department in a
position to publicize some of that major
difference which I think shows up in the
legislature um thank you for the
question representative McKay it's a
difficult one um the department uh
was given this program in 20133 as an
unfunded mandate no State funds no
general fund dollars go to support the
program it's entirely self-funded um it
is uh for for some a controversial
program um we have in our department a
bureau of drug and alcohol Services
which is focused on uh prevention uh
Services as well so there is uh some um
this complexity there in terms of
messaging um historically over the past
10 years the department has not
publicized
or advertised this program obviously we
do have a website you know that um talks
about our therapeutic cannabis program
Services we have done a number of press
releases um when the uh when the
situation calls for it like for instance
when uh a new a new uh dispensary would
open so there is some um public facing
you know um activities that the
department engages in but generally
speaking um we don't engage in
advertising program um we would
prefer patients enrollment or
registration with a program to be based
on a conversation between a patient and
their medical provider um and uh we
would then provide all the information
um that is appropriate you know to
provide so I I appreciate the question
um could we do more would I like to do
more perhaps um but uh we're we're in a
place where it's a program that serves
patients um we educate providers um but
we don't advertise the program
necessarily I hope
that answers your question
somewhat other questions thank you very
much thank you Mr H thank
you also signed up to speak is The
Honorable
sua once again from Sam New Hampshire
thank you um if I could before I start
sir to answer your question the reason
that that there doesn't need to be more
advertisement from the Cannabis the
state's cannabis program is there is
really a NeverEnding bench of PR
marijuana advocating Lobby organizations
that are doing Yan's work on that behalf
um I just want to say uh Sam New
Hampshire opposes this bill it's
well-meaning very well- meaning and I
understand uh with regard to medical
marijuana users who live far from atc's
or who may struggle with the cost of
purchasing product however it also
represents a clear expansion of the
medical marijuana program that has
issues serious issues with enforcement
and oversight we've all heard today that
there is it's the honor System plain and
simple was just the honor System uh
currently the state's uh program
office the Cannabis program office or
even the department of AG agriculture
culture have zero bandwidth to provide
any kind of um oversight to this program
they they don't they won't have the
ability to enforce whether or not the
marijuana grower is only producing
medical marijuana for one of their
potential five legal met medical
marijuana patients they will not be able
to ensure that they're producing more
than eight ounces of usable marijuana or
to ensure that they're not making more
than $500 in annual sales in addition it
also um does not include any language
that would address non Financial in-kind
barter payments which would allow for
some potential
malfeasance uh with the law in addition
the bill clarifies that the names of the
individuals enrolled in the state's uh
program will not be disclosed by any
agency and if law enforcement has any
concerns about a residence then they
must submit a sworn affidavit which
includes the Grower's name and date of
birth which must include and then the
state agency in the language says may
may confirm if they are a designated
caregiver the state is not compelled to
give this information to law enforcement
at all in addition any warrants the law
enforcement may have um may have are
protected from
91a uh inquiries so even neighbors of an
illegal growing operation or a grow
operation that's outside the confines of
the program will have no idea of
criminal activity in their CL close
proximity if a person violates the bill
by growing more marijuana than allowed
and selling it to four of their other
five potential medical marijuana
patients or any else anything else in
violation the only punishment so far is
a loss of a medical marijuana card I
know that there's been some discussions
about the extra penalties that Growers
have but grower um caregivers caregivers
according to um another law that we'll
discuss here HB 380 it actually says
that they get penalized another felony
if they if they sell to non-med
marijuana patients so just like a
recreational user well funny HB 380 is
right now in committee to be you know to
be repealed back so in addition um you
know the hopes to eliminate the felony
for medical marijuana users who sell
their marij marijuana to non-medical
people when combined with the efforts of
hp53 it hamstrings law enforcement
Personnel from their Public Safety
Mission and it opens up a huge Pandora's
Box if we could start wrapping up please
yes sir uh lastly I'll just say that
this also establishes that atcs can
start a new line of business as seedling
Distributors this bill allows no limit
on the amount of seedlings that they can
have and again I just want to say that a
lot of these bills as recreational
marijuana is diminishing what you're
seeing is a flood of bills to open up
for the marijuana medical marijuana side
of things although well-intentioned um
at this time I I think that the
oversight is too problematic to pass
thank you any
questions I'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is Matt Simon
from Green Leaf
cannabis thank you Mr chairman again
Matt Simon Granite Leaf cannabis we
support this bill I've personally been
trying to pass this bill for 18 years I
pleased that this committee has passed
it many times I'm pleased that the house
has passed it many times times I hope
this will happen yet again in
2025 L been said already I want to focus
on first of all for us this is not a
bottom line issue we're not expecting to
make money off of selling seedlings our
team cares about our patients we care
about cannabis if our patients want to
grow most won't want to grow but those
who do our staff would like to teach
classes on cultivation we would like to
support them any way that we can this is
a propati bill for us a freedom issue
not a bottom line issue at
all so representative Marquel you asked
about the policies in other states let's
just I want to be really clear about
this as New Hampshire's been debating
this for the last 12 years every other
state in New England has legalized home
cultivation of cannabis not just for
registered patients but for all adults
21 and older who counts the plants in
these states nobody it's the same as
home brewing it's assumed that people
are following the law and if somebody
gets arrested and is found to be
engaging in an illegal business that is
a crime and that's treated as a crime
what are the current penalties in New
Hampshire very important it is a felony
in New Hampshire to quote unquote
manufacturer marijuana in any amount
over 1 ounce it's an RSA RSA 318 B2
controlled Drug Act penalties it's a
felony for anybody to grow a plant the
bill that you heard about in another
committee is trying to repeal a
different felony when we passed the
therapeutic cannabis law we created a
new felony that only applies to
registered patients and caregivers who
violate the provisions of 126 acts so
currently it's actually two felonies if
a patient were to be caught growing and
they could be charged with both of them
the other bill is based on the idea that
one felony would be sufficient so it
will be a felony if this passes for
anybody in New Hampshire to to grow
cannabis it would only be exempting
registered patients and caregivers who
comply with all of the provisions and
the requirements that they report the
cultivation location
Etc representative Nagel you brought up
uh other
drugs I think that's an important
convers ation for us to continue to have
because when I look at the laws that are
on the books both nationally and in New
Hampshire I don't see a lot of laws that
criminalize nature I think that nature
is basically there for people to use
unless there is a specific prohibition
cannabis is a plant that the law and its
Majesty has seen fit to prohibit I'm not
aware of a law that says I can't go
Harvest willow bark if that was
something I wanted to do and use it as
an alternative to aspirin not saying
somebody should do that but I think
cannabis can be grown reliably in
controlled circumstances and this law
would allow for that and most
importantly patients are not well served
by the threat of felony penalties so
thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you I'm sorry representative Nagel thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I I I totally agree with
everything that have said about access
being a problem um in terms of cost and
everything have the dispensaries and
whomever um sat down thought about
strategies for reducing cost in other
ways than than
this absolutely we talk about that all
the time we certainly hear from patients
patients are shop are able to go to
neighboring states and see the markets
in neighboring states the prices are
lower so three of the bills you're
hearing today would deal with the cost
issue in some way uh the the CB bill
from earlier would allow us to produce
some products more more affordably the
for-profit conversion bill this
afternoon would reduce our operating
cost
substantially uh and this is one that on
the patient side would allow patients to
to reduce their own costs if they see
fit so we're looking at from a bunch of
different angles always trying to do the
best job we can serving
patients any other questions
representative
marel thank you Mr chair um just out of
curiosity since you're in the business
correct okay can't you ship it to
people uh cannabis or marijuana is it
still called ferally is ferally illegal
so uh we absolutely can't ship anything
out out of state that would be a
cannabis product uh regulated cannabis
markets are all entirely
inate uh based on the a that everything
has to be produced and sold in state
right but what I'm suggesting is one of
the key issues here that I heard was
that people need access because they
either can't transport or whatever and
I'm wondering if there's some sort of
way that you can transport directly to
your customers and it doesn't
necessarily have to be by means of
interstate commerce so you mean like a a
personal delivery yeah provision almost
like delivering pizza well there are
states that allow delivery New Hampshire
has chosen not to do that and we don't
have a bill on that subject thank you
other
questions okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Dr Joe
Hannon good
morning better better okay very good my
wife does like to amplify my voice at
home so I'm not used to this um anyway
uh I was a member of the 2018 um
commission to study legalization and
taxation of uh marijuana they called it
at the time and uh I was also one of the
two people who was uh C tasked with
reviewing scientific articles to bring
back to the group to discuss I'm also a
board member for Advisory Board member
for the New Hampshire cannabis
Association um and I'd like to address a
couple things that were said some of
them were brought up already but I think
it's important to reiterate um
section 175 5B of um production of beer
and wine for personal and family use
just under 200 gallons or more year
allowed if you have two or more adults
over 21 and only 100 gallons or less of
beer wine if you're just a single adult
over 21 in the household uh there are no
checks no registry no
inspections and I don't think there's
been any problems that have been and I
haven't seen any problems if there's
been any arrests or um anything going on
I have not heard of it or seen it um if
may exist but we don't see it uh and the
commission when we looked at that we
also realized that it was not a big
issue no one really cared about that
because um as far as enforcing it and
who's going to check it it works for
alcohol and and beer for beer and wine
why why mess with it for here uh we
allow that for recreational purposes now
we're talking about medicine um and you
said that there is no Dr drugs that we
allow allow medicines that we allow
people to make but we do allow people to
make a drug we allow people to make the
drug alcohol at home for recreational
use um this is something that I think if
people were able to make their own
penicillin and scrape their own bread
and take their own willow bark off to
make their aspirin they probably would
um if it was that expensive you know we
hear about insulin prices and Narcan
prices and all these other things out
there we're doing everything we can to
lower drug prices except this this is
something that is important to patients
and New Hampshire has recognized that
this is a medicine for patients who need
it for their health happiness and
well-being um thise not not passing this
prevents that uh at a certain level and
it was discussed that there are certain
strains that we can't get for people and
patients uh certain um things that are
better for individuals uh we have a very
limited market because we only have a
few institutions that are allowed to
make medicinal cannabis um people do go
out of state they are going to go find
it from someone else we have very little
on the street in New Hampshire that is
being sold sold uh from you know elicit
elicit purposes it's still there it's
going to be for a while until it's
completely legalized at the federal
level I believe but um I think this is
something that is not going to be a
pervasive problem uh the amount of
people that actually will grow it is way
less than we expect that that we I said
people in this room I'm I'm saying
because I'm not going to grow it I know
a lot of people that would like to and
they're going to start to try it and
then they're going to realize how
difficult it actually is to get what
they're looking for um let I just real
quick like to just say that you know
there's a lot of poisonous plants out
there that I could grow a a Hemlock Farm
Nightshade Fox Glove I can make a whole
row of the stuff in my backyard with no
fence nothing kids can walk in dogs can
come and eat it perfectly legal not
going to do that but it's perfectly
legal in New Hampshire we're talking
about something that's going to be
locked up secured just like it is at the
atc's and um I think there's no reason
not to do this to allow people to have a
choice to be happy to be healthier and
and to to be Freer as people in New
Hampshire so I I beg you to please pass
this law pass this bill into law and I'd
be happy to take any questions thank you
any
questions seeing that thank
you also signed up to speak is Adam
Mulholland Mr malland you've asked for
five minutes I'd prefer it closer to
three okay thank
you turn on your mic there you go sorry
first time I testified um I'm the exact
person for this bill I'm a patient I'm a
disabled veteran um before I came to New
Hampshire when I finished my service I
was on morphine and Oxycodone for uh
four years and it it took my ability to
be able to speak and and have
conversations and interact
in the public and when I came to New
Hampshire I realized we had all this
access around us not necessarily in New
Hampshire um so I joined the medical
program and it's helped me tremendously
to uh get off of of the opiods and
everything else uh I like a lot of
people that are in the program are for
pain management and we're on fixed
incomes it's very expensive to buy the
amount of product that we need to uh
help us on our day-to-day activities
something like this would help offset
that cost um like it said before many
people aren't going to grow it it's a
very very small minority of people that
would do it uh this is so helpful for
people like myself I've talked to many
people uh I ran for office last year and
I was able to go to a lot of doors in in
my community to um to discuss stuff like
this and there was a lot of support in
my community so I know it's not just me
I think this would free up a lot of us
um instead of just having to go over to
Maine or mass or wherever people get
their stuff um this is very beneficial I
don't think uh the plant number is is
very important it's a very arbitrary
number same with the amounts um most
people are just going to want to grow
their medicine and consume it in their
house anyway um I just don't see um I
don't see this as a problem I don't
think it's going to turn anybody into a
drug dealer I don't think it's going to
turn anybody into uh a criminal we just
simply want our medicine and being able
to grow a seed and know that I'm G to
get what I what I need out of it um as
far as strains go if I can if I can find
something um in those seeds that work
for me I can reproduce it at home I can
clone it just like everybody else does
around the United States and and outside
um this is super helpful because going
from strain to strain going to an ATC
and trying everything is is very
expensive and pretty prohibitive um for
people like myself that that have the
significant amount of pain to manage so
I'm very glad to see this bill come
through I hope that it'll be passed and
um thank you I'll take any questions
being behing thank you very much any
questions representative n thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question I'm
just I'm just curious because I was
looking at the bill and all the
requirements on how you grow set it up
you know everything have you looked into
what it would cost to do that at your
house to just do the setup not actually
grow it but sure I I'm familiar I have
friends in Maine and and elsewhere that
that have attempted it and otherwise um
yeah you need basic things like any
other plant would need
umt invisible microphone oh sorry this
has to be totally invisible from you
know the street it has to be a structure
of some sort fencing or whatever I I I
don't think any patient is going to go
out of their way to build a a structure
for Three Mature plants I mean you're
talking about a very small footprint for
for something like that uh most people
are probably going to pick a room in
their house and and just use it um three
plants would take up very small space
it's it's nothing um huge so I don't
think that would be an enormous task to
to
handle thank you for the question other
questions seeing none okay thank you sir
thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 53 would anyone else like to
testify seeing no one I am gonna
close I'm sorry he had his hand up and
then he took it down okay does does
somebody want to testify in
hp53 okay all right then I'm going to
close the public hearing on hp53 uh we
are scheduled to begin the hearing on HB
205 FN in about 3 minutes so we'll be in
a brief recess until
then
e
e e
okay um I'd like to
reconvene um the next bill to can be
considered I want to open the public
hearing on hb50 205 FN and recognize the
prime sponsor representative Heath
Howard thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members uh I'm representative
Heath Howard I represent the towns of
straford and barington in straford
District 4 and I introduced hb25 because
of a situation that I had talking with
one of my
constituents uh so this constituent uh
they received Care at the VA and the
thing is is that because of the federal
illegality of cannabis at the federal
level and the fact that this uh
constituent went to a federal doctor
they weren't able to get uh
certification for therapeutic cannabis
so that meant that they had to then look
for a third party physician and pay out
of pocket in order to get their
certification I broke my back when I was
16 I've I've had multiple surgeries it
cost me $50 to get my certification for
this individual it cost them
$170 to me somebody paying three times
the amount to get a certification it
shouldn't be that way and if they are
going to be paying that much out of
pocket at least we could give them a $50
rebate in a sense even if they are going
to be paying more than twice what I
would have had to pay for my
certification uh however I have talked
to a few people especially over at the
TCM o about some of their concerns about
this legislation which I was unaware of
beforehand in the fact that this could
potentially cut 10% of their funding uh
I do think that that's a very notable uh
thing to bring up because it is a
self-funded program and it does kind of
bring Delight whether or not there needs
to be additional funding if we want to
pursue this type of path uh with that
being said I'm open to any questions
thank you thank you any
questions representative Nel the
question you don't ask is the one you
always wish you ask so I'm G to ask this
one anyways I'm can you explain the $170
I'm confused about that yes so uh this
constituent because they had to look for
a third- party physician uh in order to
get their certification they had to pay
out of pocket because because they don't
have uh Insurance since they go to a VA
doctor uh so because of this they had to
pay I I don't know if it was $170 uh
total uh with the certification or uh if
it was $120 plus the $50 certification
fee other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you oh o signed up to speak is uh
representative Wendy Thomas who is a
co-sponsor of the
bill oh hey it's me again uh for the
record I am Wendy Thomas and I represent
the town of marac I am here to tepidly
support House Bill
205 I am a co-sponsor of this bill
because I believe we need to begin the
conversation of allowing veterans to use
therapeutic cannabis through the VA for
pain illness and PT P SD the the VA is
currently prohibited from certifying
patients for the program this is true in
every state all patients who use the VA
for their medical care and who want to
access therapeutic cannabis must go
elsewhere for provider
certification outside the VA systems
veterans effectively don't have health
insurance which was what was referenced
earlier so the providers that veterans
can find in the community charge a
significant Fe fee which is cash out of
pocket however many other patients not
just veterans don't have providers who
can certify and those patients find the
same providers and pay the same high
fees these are not ideal circumstances
for any patients I believe our veterans
have sacrificed for our country and
should be acknowledged however if we
exclude p uh veterans which make up a
little over 1,500 or roughly 10% of the
therapeutic patient count in New
Hampshire we run the risk of financially
impacting the program for the other
approximately 13,500 patients in New
Hampshire the therapeutic program is
self-funded by the annual and now up to
three-year licensing fees removing
veteran patients could have the
unintended consequence of impacting the
program's funding going
forward the fiscal note on the bill says
no impact because even though the
program Revenue would be reduced on
under this bill the statutory funding
structure means that we would Bill we
would Bill the atcs for the Lost Revenue
so by their math it's Revenue neutral
but it's definitely a cost shift to
patients so while I acknowledge the
sacrifice of our veteran that the these
sacrifice our veterans have made to our
country and while I firmly believe that
therapeutic cannabis should be embraced
as a medical modality for our veteran
patients I am honestly not sure that
this is the best way to approach the
issue however I will leave that decision
in the capable hands of this committee
thank you very much and I'll take any
questions thank you any
questions okay I'm saying none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Sue
hamala from Sam New Hampshire
thank you very much um I just want to
start by letting you know from
perspective wise I've spent seven years
on active duty I spent 20 plus years as
a military spouse three of my four
children are currently on active duty in
the Air Force Marines and navy I
understand the well-meaning intent of
the Prime sponsor I think the the bill
is well-intentioned
um however we also have to keep in mind
the alternative treatment centers
already offer discounted product for
veterans and um and I if I read the 2022
therap therapeutic cannabis program
correctly all of the discounts that the
atc's give each one of them it seems if
I read it correctly is into the tune of
a half a million dollars a year and I'm
sure U Mr Simon could correct me if
that's incorrect uh the concern that I'm
here to discuss is that medical studies
are still catching up to the narrative
that marijuana is safe and effective
treatment for PTSD a study published in
psychology psychology psychological
medicine part of me in 2020 suggest
quote cannabis use is linked with
greater severity of trauma related
intrusion symptoms over time a strong
person Le uh level directional
association between PTSD and cannabis
use disorder was evident findings have
significant findings have significant
clinical imp implications for the
long-term effect of cannabis use among
individuals with PTSD another quote
findings based on the STA statistically
rigorous models utilized in our and
other perspective studies do not support
the widespread State sanctioned medical
use of cannabis for the treatment of
PTSD for these individuals recommending
cannabis cessation and seeking
evidence-based treatment for PTSD may
help to improve the outcomes and
mitigate the risks of cannabis use
disorder uh in addition only this past
November did the does the VA the VA the
FDA just authorized a clinical trial to
study using marijuana to treat PSD and
Veterans the reason I'm breaking this up
is because this illustrates our state's
cart before the horse approach when it
comes to adding clinical diagnosis on
the medical marijuana list of conditions
it can
treat uh we also are disinterested in
actually looking at studies uh that
actually um over time can prove like
PTSD that there may be some concerns
that we have about uh saying that
medical marijuana is a is a cure all for
that interestingly in 2013 Democratic
governor uh Maggie Hassen demanded that
in HB 573 at that time to remove PTSD
from the Bill's language I mean this
isn't necessarily a uh this is a long
discussion that we've had in our
state the state of New Hampshire is
already I would say acting a little
irresponsibly by including PTSD in the
list of approved medical marijuana
conditions our state is currently
misleading veterans on the safety of
using medical marijuana to treat PSD
PTSD and we should not make it easier to
mislead them into thinking that
marijuana is an appropriate Cure All by
removing the $50 fee thank you thank you
any
questions seeing no questions thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative J
kerk I think representative kerk and
representative Thomas have a competition
as to who's going to speak the most
today
but and I'm former not not not active
um yes so once again I serve as a chair
of the oh for the record my name is
Jerry kerk and I serve as the chair of
the New Hampshire therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board um so you the
summary of this again is it would the
the bill would exempt veterans from
paying the $50 application fee for the
program and the card you get is valid
for 3
years this was a fascinating time in our
meeting uh earlier in the month because
we really had a hard time reaching any
kind of a consensus on this we took
three different votes on three different
motions and they were all really split
the members were very conflicted because
though we support the concept of
honoring the veterans and reducing
barriers to accessing the program we
recognize the fiscal impact of this bill
upon the therapeutic program the
alternative treatment centers and the
patients we noted that veterans even
those who have not served in combat are
more susceptible to PTSD which is an
approved qualifying medical condition
some members of the board they also
pointed out that other professions are
equally at risk of PTSD for example law
enforcement and firefighters and they
would be similarly
deserving as been pointed out veterans
do face a specific crle because they
cannot uh the the VA doc not only will
not certify they won't even talk to you
about it uh but there's also other
patients that face that burden patients
of federal League qualified Health
Centers and some group practices also
are not able to get certified in their
practice where they receive their
treatment so this would improve access
for those few Veterans for which the $50
application is a burden but the $50 fee
is minor compared to the cost of the
product and only some veterans are low
income
the atcs already are required by allow
to give discounts to patients on SSI
SSDI and Medicaid and they all also
offer discounts on products for
veterans and again though the fiscal
note states that the impact will be zero
that is because of how the program is
structured there'll simply be a cost
shifting of this lost Revenue to the
atcs which therefore goes to the other
registered patients since about 10% of
our 15,000 registered patients are vet
veterans this bill would yield about
1,500 patients who would be exempt of
the $50 fee they're valid for 3 years so
we'd lose about $75,000 of income every
3 years but since the program is
statutorily mandated to be
self-funded this uh will result in
higher annual registration fees that are
passed on to the atc's and they will
have to pass those costs on to the other
patients so the fact
to the state budget is zero the effect
to the other patients is going to be
real so in summary even though the
members of TCM o strongly agreed with
the concept of supporting our veterans
and reducing access barriers to access
we also recognized the fiscal impact and
the cost shifting that will occur and
therefore voted to to not support the
bill by a margin of 5 to one but with
three extensions we it was really a
fascinating experience to watch this uh
difficulty because we were all so
conflicted I'll take any questions okay
any
questions seeing no questions sure thank
you thank
you also signed up to speak is Michael
Holt from the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human
Services and again Mr Hol you asked for
five if it's keep keep it closer to
three I bet I can do it in two okay for
the record my name is Michael Hol I'm
the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services um my
testimony is going to be very similar to
those um who came before me so I'll keep
it brief um uh the department does not
have a position on this bill um hb25 is
a challenging Bill to talk about the
program supports removing barriers to
patients access the program including
costs and fees since the program began
in 2016 the program has never raised its
fees in fact we have reduced fees we
have waved fees and we have even got uh
eliminated fees going to the legislature
to change the law to uh to to remove
some of the fees um recently the program
implemented a law change that allows a
provider's written certification to be
good for up to three years at a time we
did not increase our rates it was $50
for a year and it's now $50 for three
years so every patient on the program
has already within the past two years
experienc a substantial uh cost savings
with regard to our uh uh the patient
application fee um and the the program
is dealing with a up to two-thirds uh
Revenue reduction already based on that
uh um that that policy change so
ideologically it's challenging to be
faced with not being able to support a
bill that removes a barrier to access
lowers fees for a certain patient
population um so as you know this would
exempt veterans um we know that the
current fee is $50 uh there are 15,000
registered patients on the program 1500
are veterans that's 10% of our
population it's a 10% reduction um in
our Revenue $75,000 over three years
$25,000 annually um the fiscal note as
has been said States no impact but
that's due to the self-funding nature of
the program which means that the the
loss of Revenue will be passed on to the
atcs in terms of their registration fees
um and then if they can if the atc's or
if an ATC can't absorb those costs those
uh have the potential of being passed on
to to patients themselves I just want to
emphasize again no general fund dollars
have ever been spent on the startup or
the maintenance of this program it's
100% funded by patient application fees
and ATC licensing fees um and just to
close you know the the issue with with
regard to Veterans they do face a
particular challenge as you've heard
they uh the VA is prohibited federally
from uh issuing certifications to state
legal programs uh marijuana programs and
this is the case throughout the country
um it's a nationwide issue um but the
challenge is not unique to Veterans I
would offer and that is um people who
receive their Primary Medical Care from
federally qualified Health Centers um
are also federally prohibited um from uh
getting certifications from their
providers um and in practice many other
patients simply can't find a provider uh
to certify them um their provider may be
unwilling to certify or they may be part
of a practice group that prohibits their
doctors from participating all of these
patients veterans and U patients who
can't find a doctor um they most often
end up seeing a provider in the
community who advertises cannabis
certification most of whom charge a very
high fee as you describe um so it's just
to reiterate it's not a unique patient
to Veterans um although the the federal
prohibition is is is a stark one in
terms of their access to the program um
I'll finish there I'm happy to take
questions um if anyone has any any
questions representative delus and then
representative L
montine thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question is it cost prohibitive if you
you were to say raise the fees across
the board to from 50 to 55 for a
threeyear certification or I'm not sure
is there a way to to sort of balance
things out so that the the veterans
would be given a
break we have Ru making Authority where
we can change our fees uh by going
through rules so what while that is
possible um it is not consistent with
our approach over the past 10 years
which is to not raise fees one of the
Hallmarks of our program uh we have some
pride in the fact that we haven't raised
fees um uh for patients um but you know
but it is it is certainly it is
certainly possible now that we're facing
currently a two-thirds reduction in
Revenue because of our not raising fees
um uh from a one-year card to a
three-year card we are we are facing
that um that proposition um the
structure in place as you've heard would
be uh for us to build the atcs um for
that um and we would uh weigh that
approach against the approach of raising
fees um uh to application fees for
certain patient groups um if I had my
way I would um and if I looking at it
more broadly I would be more interested
as the program administrator to um have
reduced fees for categorical uh
financially disadvantaged uh people um
uh Medicaid recipients SSI recipients
people on SSDI etc those would be my
first choice chice to raise to eliminate
or reduce fees people who are by their
by their category are financially
disadvantaged and as we know veteran
status is not necessarily A categorical
Financial um hardship
class representative lontine and then
representative Weber thank you for
taking my question did you say that
sometimes you do wave the fees and under
what
circumstances uh good pickup uh uh the
uh the the the time that we waved fees
was during covid um where we uh waved
caregiver fees to encourage patients to
designate caregivers um so that there
were opportunities or options in case
somebody got sick they could still
access their medicine via someone else
so we tried to encourage um the uh the
the uptake of the caregivers by waving
those fees and in fact that was the fee
that we ended up uh removing entirely
via statute um uh once Co ended
um by eliminating the the the fee for um
for
caregivers representative Weber and then
representative
Neland I think you actually may have
addressed this but I I just want to be
sure I've got it clear in my own head so
um if we wave the fees for
veterans it's not am I correct in
understanding it's not that the fees go
up for other people but the the cost
shortfall in the program is passed
around to the
atc's and they in turn may need based on
whatever their financial models are to
raise prices across the board and that's
the way it might impact a cost shift on
other patients is that do I have that
mechanism right yes that's how we've
that's how we and other people have
testified to frame the issue that is a
cost shift down um but as the other
representative mentioned um if we were
to if the program were to raise their
fees for everyone else um then perhaps
that cost shift down to the atcs
wouldn't be as as great could be either
way and I would also offer that um you
know it's it it's $25,000 a year split
between three different companies so it
may not be significant the atc's may be
able to absorb those costs so it's not
necessarily the prices will be increased
um however they may not be able to lower
their prices as quickly um and as we've
seen cost is a is is a great barrier to
accessing um the product um and and so
it may not be a Ono one we have to raise
our prices but they may not come down as
quickly um so thank you thank you for
that clarification representative
nagan all set any other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Adam
molland and and once again sir you asked
for five please try to keep it to three
this will take a minute okay I just want
to say somebody like myself uh I get
seen at the VA and when I went for
certification uh I have to establish uh
a relationship with another doctor that
I'm not normally going to see uh some
websites if you look online require
three four uh visits at
$150 plus each um again this is not a
doctor I necessarily want to treat me
I'm just trying to get certification as
a as a VA individual I can't get it at
there so um I don't know how to reduce
those costs for veterans I I agree that
this bill is somewhere in the middle and
um I can understand the split votes here
but overall at least for veterans uh in
some cases we have to incur hundreds of
dollars uh and then a $50 fee just to
get our card and uh I don't know how to
reduce that overall or or limit the um
the financial exposure that we have many
of us being on fixed incomes and this is
something that many of us actually need
um that's all I have if there's any
questions sure thank you representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question this is a would you
believe I'm I'm so impressed that you've
been able to find a doctor that only
charges $120 for this so would you
believe that most doctors charge
substantially more than that's why would
you believe that the cost is probably
dramatically higher I I fully agree I I
got pretty lucky um when I when I found
uh somebody to certify me and um you
know insurance doesn't cover that it it
comes completely out of the pocket so
you know if it helps veterans in the
future um that's what my hope is thank
you represent represented Woods thank
you Mr chair and uh thank you for taking
my question which you may not be able to
answer uh do you have any insight as to
the prevalence of the a similar problem
in the general medical field in other
words other than veterans are there
people who uh similarly find their
physician
either just doesn't want to or doesn't
feel qualified and they also then have
to get another relationship do we have
any insight as to the prevalence of that
I can offer antidotal uh evidence said
you may not able to answer the question
but I did reach out to um like my kids
physicians to see if they would take me
as a new patient I'd have to go through
that process and many of them already
said that they would not certify they
didn't feel comfortable um doing so so
um I was stuck to Google and hopefully
you know finding somebody that would do
it but I would imagine other people in
similar situations would run into the
similar similar events
thank you for the question other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Kevin M
Grady from the state Veteran's advisory
committee uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you ladies and gentlemen of the
committee for the my name is Kevin Grady
I'm a 25y year Air Force veteran and I'm
a 27e resident of the town of hookit New
Hampshire today I'm here representing
the 20 member organizations in the state
veterans advisory committee we're
chartered by state
rsa5 col
a-8 if you want to look us up you can
also find us through the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
website um and our our Charter is
essentially to let you know what
veterans are thinking and our 20 members
are are organizations that would be
familiar to you the American Legion the
the Veterans of Foreign Wars we even
have a couple of motorcycle groups on
there motorcycle combat U motorcycle
Veterans of America and and rolling
thunder are in our group I personally
represent the air and space forces
Association I'm also our legislative
chair which means I go through all of
the bills that are coming before the
Senate and the house and the ones that
have veteran impact we discuss those at
our monthly meeting and we come up with
a position and then I come and tell you
what that position is and I thank you
for indulging me because this is a
committee that I don't see very often to
be honest with you I I tend to see I'm
over over in state federal uh uh
relations and Veteran Affairs is kind of
where I do most of of the work that I do
we're we're tracking 18 Bills going
through on this particular go around
this bill did not Garner a lot of what
you'd call support when we talked about
it and I would say in opposition is
really a stronger word than what we felt
we we was more like we just don't
support it and the reason for that is
that the legislature has done an
exceptional job almost across the board
of trying to do things for veterans
every single chance that they get and
all of us in that room when we discuss
this are taxpayers just like all of you
and all of all of us know that as a
state we're facing a budget shortfall
now I know some of the budget people
might say well I find that kind of money
in my in the seat cushions of my sofa at
home but um to us number one we don't
want the impression that every time you
see Kevin Grady up here he's got his
hand out looking for money for veterans
we don't want that to be the impression
that we leave you and as taxpayers too
we feel like this this is one of those
ones we can pass on in other words this
is one of those ones where it doesn't
affect a large enough number of veterans
that we're as concerned about it and and
quite frankly it doesn't Target the kind
of Veterans for help that we're looking
for the folks with the traumatic brain
injury that are never going to be able
to work again those are the people we
want to see the property tax exemptions
for and some of those kinds of things so
this was one where we decided that the
political capital capital was more than
we were willing to expend I guess to use
a political term on this and so we we we
do not support this legislation and I'll
take any questions that you happen to
have I I see the representative has one
uh representative Weber and then
representative
Nagel so I heard in the course of that
lukewarm support not
opposing and um not supporting is that
how do I write that down on my notes is
that no position or is that officially I
have it down in my in my notes as
opposition we opposed this bill that was
what the vote was but the discussion was
mostly that we that that we didn't see
the need for this legislation in the
grand scheme of things of all the other
things that we're looking at not only
this go around but other go arounds
thank you very much for that
clarification representative Nagel thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um I'm a little confused my
specialty is pain management um I've
done a lot of work with veterans over
the years the incidence of pain in
combat vets is about 60% of chronic pain
lifelong the most common use of cannabis
therapeutic cannabis is actually for
pain not PTSD so what I'm confused about
is it would seem to me that this would
be a good thing for um managing that
element of of veterans and I will say
that in my experience people kind of
neglect that aspect of of their care and
to me this is a good statement wouldn't
it
be I'm I'm certainly not an expert on
marijuana I I've never never smoked
marijuana even when I was a kid and and
it's not just because I'm a goodie two
shoes which I am a little bit but it's
it's also because I grew up in a home
with two two parents that smoke two
packs of cigarettes a day I don't want
the smoke in my in my system and I
understand that there are gummies and
other things and if I got to the point
where I needed this that might be
something that I would look at I I I
think that a a better Source here a
better I don't know better better tack
would be to try to get our congrat
delegation to work with the VA and and
see if we can't just get this thing
fixed and get this stuff def dispensed
through the VA uh again I don't know
what the political will is to do that
but that would seem a better solution
than this which we sort of view as a
workaround other
questions say no other questions thank
you sir thank you sir thanks for the
opportunity no no one else has signed up
to testify on hb25 FN does anyone anyone
else U wish to
testify seeing N I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 205 FN our next
hearing is scheduled for 100 PM which
will be addressing hb31 we stand in
recess
e
e good afternoon everyone welcome
back we uh have two more hearings to be
conducted today the first one will be on
House Bill 301 and I will recognize
representative Su representative Suzanne
Vale for the purposes of introducing the
bill welcome representative
Vale thank you Mr chair and um thank you
to The Honorable members of this
committee for hearing my bill um today
I'm Suzanne Vale and I'm state
representative from ward 3 in NASA which
is Hillsboro County 6 and I'm here to
present House Bill
301 which is relative to the cultivation
locations for alter alternative
treatment
centers um if you have the bill before
you I think it's easiest to just look at
it and um line by line what we are
asking for is for the alternative
treatment centers to be able to to have
additional locations for cultivation
only and these locations can be a
greenhouse these green houses would be
the same they would go under the same
rigorous Town approval before being able
to have rules adopted um the department
will work with the town
government as far as it needs to be
during during this bill so you may
recall that this bill went through the
legislature last year but it was vetoed
by the governor and he was concerned
that it was
unregulated um at the time and so his
concerns were well listened to but we
wanted to just continue to assert that
this bill really is about an additional
location and it's not about imposing
this location on a town I ATC would have
to go through the rigorous Town
approvals that need to happen in order
for this to take place and there's a lot
of good reasons why this bill would be
helpful but I'm just going to give you a
couple of um overview and then I believe
that there's a lot of testimony behind
me that will um make it come into view
let me just pull up my
thing
sorry so the atcs are currently required
to cultivate cannabis in an enclosed and
locked facility this means they must
grow under high-intensity lights and um
those are not the same as using sunshine
and utilizing natural sunlight changes
the product that we actually can
create Greenhouse cultivation is more
economical for many reasons that are
probably pretty obvious the
high-intensity lights and the energy
bills are incredibly expensive and and
this gets passed on to the patient you
know as it's
unavoidable allowing Greenhouse
cultivation would also make um result in
more affordable cannabis for the
patients who are involved in the
program neighboring states also allow
green houses in order to support their
medical
dispensaries and with that I close my
testimony but I'm happy to take any
questions that can um that can help the
committee understand thank you any
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you Mr
shair also signed up to speak as
representative Wendy
Thomas like a bad
penny for the record in case you have
forgotten I am Wendy Tom and I represent
the town of marac I am here in support
of House Bill 301 which is an act
relative to cultivation locations for
alternative treatment centers hb31 would
be benei would be a beneficial addition
to New Hampshire's therapeutic program
for several reasons first allowing
alternative treatment centers which are
atc's to operate additional cultivation
locations such as green houses addresses
the growing demand for therapeutic
cannabis uh with more cultivation
capacity atc's can increase their
production of cannabis ensuring that
they have a consistent and sufficient
supply of therapeutic cannabis for
patients this would be particularly
helpful in preventing shortages and
ensuring timely access to therapeutic
cannabis for qualifying
patients moreover the Bill's requirement
for input from qualifying patients
designated caregivers and local
residents before approving additional
cultivation locations Fosters
transparency and Community involvement
by engaging with the local governing
body and residents the bill ensures that
the expansion of cultivation is done in
a way that respects local concerns
zoning laws and Community Values this
collaborative approach uh promotes trust
between the atc's and local communities
which can be crucial for the long-term
success and acceptance of the
therapeutic cannabis program
Additionally the inclusion of greenhouse
green houses as a potential cultivation
site offers a more environmentally
sustainable option which could lower
operational costs and increase
production efficiency this sustainable
practice aligns with broader goals of
reducing environmental impact while
supporting the needs of the
program overall this bill helps the New
Hampshire therapeutic cannabis program
meet the growing needs of patients while
ensuring Regulatory Compliance and
Community involvement it provides a
flexible transparent and scalable
approach to meeting demand all while
maintaining the Integrity of the program
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any
questions representative
McCay chair
microphone microphone's not
on there you go
thank you uh I'm a little confused uh it
is are we talking about one
organization with various parts to it or
or several different
organizations U you you've you've got an
existing facility and then it's
expanding so I just wanted to know if
that's one organization or several
different
organizations um I I believe it's per
ATC mhm so so technically we have three
companies that run the atcs we have
seven seven uh actual physical locations
but these um and it would be up to to
the uh companies and the um Community
where these are located but for example
there's the um uh Green Leaf has the
grow facility and they might put a a
greenhouse outside of that gross
facility or in another location but this
would be um per company so we've got
three companies I think does that answer
your question uh not
exactly what I'm trying to say is that
this starts with one
organization and they're allowed to
expand is the expansion still part of
that organization
and is it one board of directors yes yes
I'm hearing it from people behind me and
that is my belief as well and I'm sure
somebody will come up and address that
that that part of
it any other questions you all
representative McKay okay um oh
representative
McGrath I thank you
um so
if this I can understand how it could
save on energy that's
huge make it more affordable meet the
growing
demand but it has nothing really to do
with the patient location so I'm just
wondering why soliciting input from
patients and caregivers is part of
that I I think so you're correct and
that it's grown in a the cannabis plants
are grown in a facility and and the
product is then shipped to the
dispensaries so it's not grown at the
dispensaries you know so um I I think
that including the the patients is just
a a good thing to do because they're
members of the program and they can give
input so I I think that that's the only
reason for that just it's good practice
to include
them other
questions seeing none thank you thank
thank
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry
coner thank you Mr chair and for the
record I'm still Jerry kerk and still
chair the therapeutic canab medical
oversight board um and uh yes we do
support this bill even though this in
some senses is not a straightforward
medical issue it impacts our patients
and therefore before we thought we
should take a stand on it uh it again
would allow additional cultivation
locations for atcs including green
houses the indoor cultivation as it is
currently required as we've said really
significantly increases cost because
it's indoor lighting uh environmental
control all that kind of stuff
Greenhouse cultivation we can take
advantage of the sun uh which is really
very helpful I actually have a
greenhouse I've had one for 10 years you
know it's been kind of cold lately but
last week I was 83 degrees in my
Greenhouse in the midday with the Sun so
you you can save some money on heating
you might have to still heat some during
the evening of course um but the there's
a lot of cost for the lighting and the
environmental controls for indoor
growing so the other thing is it's
somewhat difficult to completely
reproduce the sunlight Spectrum remember
plants evolved to be able to work with
sunlight not with indoor high-intensity
lights and so sometimes it's hard to get
their exactly the right spectrum and you
can get some cultivars that may not grow
as well in an indoor grow facility as
they might outside in the U in the
sunlight the major problem one of the
major problems for our patients is the
cost of product and anything that will
help lower the cost will make it easier
for them we do have some the most
expensive product compared to some of
our adjacent States um and as has been
noted the facilities would be subject
all of the same rules for security uh it
would just simply be that it would it be
could be open to the sky so you can use
sunlight
um the as far as soliciting information
from the patients so let's say you're
going have a hearing in the town about
whether they're going to allow a
cultivation facility because that's what
this allows this input from the
residents of the town uh well they just
know that there's going to be a building
over there or there's going to be a
greenhouse I mean but that's all they
know whereas the patients if they are
allowed to testify would be able to say
why it's an issue U you know like I'm
saying to you patients could say the
same thing in their town meeting so
that's why that's there and they're they
basically the end users so they have a
vested interest in trying to have a good
product which is cheaper um so in
essence again TCM o did support this we
voted 8 to zero to support this there
was one member who abstained that's
because he's the representative of an
ATC and he felt there was a conflict of
interest so he abstained from voting on
this um and I think that's basically it
but I think the the the issue about the
loss of security was really incorrect in
and when the when this was vetoed it
really does have the same security it's
subject to all the same rules that's
right here in the statute sorry in the
bill and so as a result we think that
there's no earthly reason why this
should not be allowed to make it better
for our patients thank you I'll take
questions thank you any
questions I'm staying done thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Michael
Holt from the Department of Health and
Human servic
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael Holt again
I'm the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services um hb31 is a
bill that the department supports um for
the the reasons already mentioned the
bill is intended um intended benefits
would be to lower product cost for
patients um and increase variety of
products to patients and uh in both
these these ways P patients would
benefit um therapeutically um and in
their wallet um the benefits of
greenhouse cultivation includes lower
production costs um uh due to a lack of
Reliance on electricity you can rely on
the sun uh also as Mr Dr kerk said um
different varieties of cannabis can be
grown that respond better to sunlight
than uh electric light um I want to
focus on the spefic spefic requirements
of the bill I mean they include most
prominently these facilities must comply
with all local zoning laws um when we
get to the question of why do we need to
solicit public input um this is uh this
has been the requirement in the statute
for all cult all facilities cannabis
facilities you know since the law first
passed so this bill is designed to not
change any processes where we would the
department would work with the local uh
town or city where it's proposed to be
um have a public hearing invite the
public and patients to come speak um so
we're trying to you know not shortcut
any or the sponsors are not trying to
shortcut any um Provisions uh
requirements that have already happened
with this uh with any cannabis facility
um security-wise um there are no
security provisions in the bill however
there's a reference to our uh the
Department's rulemaking Authority that
rule making Authority gives us um uh and
and requires us to um establish very
strict security regulations um on things
like uh uh lighting physical security
access who can get into the facilities
um alarm requirements um Etc the
security uh uh in these facilities is
robust
um and uh that should not be a reason to
not allow this you know um as well as in
we have rule making on inventory control
um and protection against diversion and
theft and and whatnot these uh these
places would will absolutely be secure
um the the Department's regulatory
Authority is sufficient to ensure ATC
compliance with the laws and the rules
and the department can operationalize
this bill within our current budget
through inspections and uh and and
whatnot so again uh the department
supports the bill because it benefits
patients um and I'm happy to take any
questions any questions represented
delus thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
green houses come in different sizes are
there do you
have or are we even do we need to be
concerned about number of plants per
square foot or how is that determined um
the law currently establishes the cap on
Plants um none of the atcs have ever
reached that cap um like I said in an
earlier testimony there's a there's a
there's a a um uh a delineated market
for this there's no Financial incen for
an ATC to grow more cannabis that it can
than it can sell um and so because of
that the caps in current law um have
never been reached um and on top of that
we have strict inventory controls uh the
department requires um a an electronic
inventory system a seed to sale
inventory system so every plant um every
ounce every fruit chew is is tracked um
and uh and accounted for so I think
there will be some learning that needs
to happen in terms of uh whether or not
uh we need additional rules for green
houses but that that's work that we're
uh the department is able to do um as
has been stated um other uh many other
states um allow for Greenhouse grows um
we'll evaluate our our current RS and
update them as needed um and uh I guess
I would say one more thing is that this
does not this bill does not allow
outdoor grows like in fields that can be
seen this it still needs to be in a
structure representative McGrath did you
have your hand
up um so people talking about the
security of the buildings and this is
medical marijuana is there an abuse
potential for the plants that are being
grown in the is that why you need the
security I'm not sure I'm not sure I
know abuse potential right
um do you mean a theft potential right
so if they steal it and they get high
off it is it is there an abuse potential
for the what's being grown in there um
cannabis if if if cannabis has THC it
does produce um Euphoria it's
intoxicating and so I believe the
reasons for such strict security
measures when the program was first
established in 2013 was to uh prevent
diversion and theft um and so the same
security protocols um have you know have
have been in place since 2013 obviously
now with the surrounding states allowing
citizens over 21 to grow their own
cannabis the risk of diversion and theft
is much lower you know in in a regional
sense so perhaps the the security
requirements that we have in place um
are you know we are too strict um I'm
not going to say that now but uh we are
not proposing to reduce any of the
security requirements that we have in
place um without fully vetting those
changes through Ru
making does that does that help thank
you other question yes represented
Lucas um with regard to security how
does the shipment between the green
houses and the
ATC how does that work
out we have a section of rules on
transport of cannabis um uh locked boxes
to ATC staff unmarked vehicles um
transport manifests um the sending
entity needs to communicate with the
receiving entity before a shipment is
taken place etc etc it's uh We've uh
honestly we've yes we've never had a in
the eight years we've been doing this
we've never had an issue with uh um a
transport other questions
seeing n okay thank you thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Sue Homa
from Sam New
Hampshire thank you for the record Sam
uh Sue hola from Sam New Hampshire uh
there are some we're here to oppose this
bill uh there's some concerns about the
language in the language it states that
green houses may be considered we just
heard Mr Holt state that there wouldn't
be outdoor growing um I'm not sure what
that means what that looks like it looks
like the language itself isn't specific
enough to to describe what type of
growing that we'd be authorizing with
this bill um one of the the one of the
things that I have a concern with is
well is that as these as these rules get
looser and we expand the medical
marijuana program
um it opens us up to more things like if
we start doing more outdoor type of grow
or Greenhouse grow um Maine's having
quite an issue with this Maine has quite
lack rules and I know that
representative McGrath had some
questions about the security aspect um
even with Main's rules even with the
fact that they have proliferated on
their state laws on what they can do for
marijuana medically and for
recreationally still hasn't stopped 200
illegal you know Chinese
um pot cartels from flooding their state
and ingratiating themselves in whenever
you start having more locations for
growing you're giving yourself more
exposure uh for that type of activity
another one of the things that I heard
um stay already was we're trying to
agress address the growing demand and as
we discussed earlier um one of the
concerns I have with the whole slate of
bills in this Committee in criminal
justice is that there is a NeverEnding
Onslaught to expand expand expand let's
be clear this is a schedule one
federally legal drug when we started
this medical marijuana program we did it
under the guise of providing
Compassionate Care but it gets very
clear that Compassionate Care isn't
really the goal it's using Compassionate
Care to keep expanding the program from
where from what it appears to me um one
of the things that I have a concern with
is that you know it's an it's an open
effort this year by one of the leading
PR marijuana associations in New
Hampshire they're they're openly
discussing about their goal this year is
to expand the enrollment of the medical
marijuana program and we heard Mr kerk
Dr kerk pardon me um was talking about
how in this bill language that there's a
a little bit in there for patients to be
notified and really it's so they can be
leveraged to go to their towns and
advocate for for this but this the
concern I have is if the goal is always
to increase users and the legislative
calendar is flooded with bills to expand
the uh the ATC Market production then
the ultimate goal of this program the
New Hampshire medical marijuana program
is not to provide a safe alternative
resource for individuals experiencing
medical conditions it's just to make
users to make more people who are using
the product
um how is that different than big Pharma
if we have to actually advertise
patients we have to tell people and AD
educate them about the marij medical
marijuana program in case it might be
useful to them and we have to use the
patients to Lobby towns so that they can
help
municipalities um cheerlead for these
efforts how exactly is this any
different than the same reasons that
drug reps were giving of why they push
oxycoton it is a federally legal drug I
think that we have long forgotten why we
established this problem yes sir long
forgotten why we've established this
program but we've established this
program and ever since this program is
established it immediately tries to get
expanded and it just is very concerning
from a drug prevention standpoint thank
you thank you any
questions not seeing any thank
you also signed up to speak is Mike mlin
from Sanctuary
ATC and if you could you've asked before
minutes sir if you could keep it closer
to three that'd be great good afternoon
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is Michael mlof I'm a lawyer and
lobbyist in con I represent Sanctuary
ATC first point I would like to make out
this legislation authorizes nothing this
is enabling legislation which provides
the authority to the Department of
Health Human Services to do what they've
been doing for the last 13 years which
is Rule and regulate the therapeutic
cannabis program so we're not
authorizing anything by this bill but
we're saying with this bill the HHS TCP
has been able to on a absolutely
scandal-free program there's been no um
issues on manufacturer distribution or
retail since this program began every
year uh in the last decade the HHS has
done a survey of the Cannabis patients
therapeutic Canabis patients in the
state and the number one issue is cost
and the cost is impacted by several
factors of number one being production
of product uh the price that is charged
the patients today is a result of
several factors one which we visit later
this afternoon but the ability to
produce product there are say atcs in
the state that literally have to buy
product from other ATC cultivation
centers because they can't produce
enough themselves so when you look at
this bill the question is do you trust
ATS to do what done for the last decade
which is regulate a program that has
been very successful there was testimony
moments ago about this being some
nefarious plot to create a marijuana
culture in the state what that ignores
is that every ch in this program has to
include other people who are suffering
from conditions that they can't get
relief from from natural other types of
therapies so to allude to the fact that
don't give this program any more
expansion is to say to people who are
suffering uh you can suffer in silence
but again this is enabling legislation
has nothing to do with author with
authorizing nothing if there's going to
be additional cultivation centers
they're going to the rigorous approval
of the HHS and believe me the approval
is incredibly um uh detailed and strict
so when you look at this bill I don't
think you should think of it's
authorizing but enabling and Trust
Michael Holt and his Department to put
together what they've already done which
is a very successful therapeutic
cannabis program which is helping over
13,000 people in this state I thank you
for your time thank you very much any
questions thank you okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Matt Simon
from Granite Leaf
cannabis thank you again Mr chairman
good afternoon Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis uh we do support
hb31 we supported at last session we're
very disappointed when it was vetoed uh
for all the reasons that have you've
heard from Mr Hol and Dr kerk uh any new
cultivation location would be subject to
all the same rules and requirements that
are applied to current cultivation
locations these are spelled out in great
length in our rules they include things
like having a camera pointed anywhere
that cannabis might be present and
maintaining video archives going back a
certain number of hours or days it is
very robust and all of those rules would
apply to any cultivation location that's
licensed under this program so the main
reason for the bill basically this bill
came about because I was talking to some
of our staff members and they said man
it would be great if we could grow some
of our cannabis in a greenhouse we could
put it over there over there is a
different address so it would have to be
a different cultivation location so we
would have to have Department approval
and the goal was not to grow more
cannabis
okay we've hosted a few tours for for
legislators and one of the rooms we
always show them is a huge empty room of
nothing the huge empty room of nothing
is space that we have available to
expand into if there was demand we could
already expand into that space and grow
more under the lights in the indoor
facility what we want to be able to do
is grow some of our cannabis differently
than the Cannabis we're currently
growing a it would be less expensive
you've already heard B it would be
create a broader range of products
because cannabis grown Outdoors is
subject to pests and sunlight and
stressors that actually make the plant
grow somewhat differently there are some
pros associated with that some cons
associated with that any of the cons get
addressed through independent lab
testing everything we produced outside
would have to be lab tested finally our
production staff in particular they work
plants all the time a lot of them feel
strongly about the environment and
wanting to reduce our carbon footprint
and growing Outdoors would achieve that
as well we're not trying to grow more
we're trying to serve our PA patients
better and operate more efficiently and
bring down costs which continues to be
the number one
concern happy to conclude there any
questions any question yes
representative
Weber so I was thank you for taking my
question and thank you Mr chairman um
when you say
Outdoors does this bill permit
cultivation both in an outside space and
in a greenhouse space or just or are you
using Outdoors as a euphemism for
Greenhouse now this bill would only
authorize uh cultivation in an enclosed
locked facility that could be a
greenhouse under this bill we thought
about asking for outdoor cultivation
which is legal in neighboring states and
nobody has an issue with that that I've
ever heard their their outdoor
cultivation is strictly regulated as
well and could theoretically be here as
well but since every single bill that
gets put in gets treated with so much
scrutiny and is treated as a massive
expansion of the program just to put
that in context uh my understanding is
that New Hampshire actually has the
lowest per capita patient participation
of any state that has a therapeutic
cannabis program with the exception of
states that have gone to adult use when
states legalize adult use patient
numbers drop but of states that are
medical cannabis only we have the lowest
per capita patient count so if that's
all we've been trying to do year after
year with SLO the bills to expand the
program we've improved some things on
paper but this is still a very small and
very tightly regulated program and it
would remain so if this passes and may I
have a FL please and because I was one
of the legislators who did get to
observe your facility in Peterboro would
you detail for those who have not what
your security procedures are there both
for your employees entering and leaving
the facility and for visitors who want
to visit the facility just so we know
what they are yeah I think that's thank
you for the question it's it would be
hard for me to detail them all because I
myself get confused checking into our
facility sometime you feel like you're
walking into Fort Ox uh some people joke
that we're regulating cannabis like
plutonium and and it does feel that way
sometimes uh but to get in the building
uh for staff have have to fob in we
always have to have two employees in the
facility at any given time so two people
have to show up and two people have to
check out everybody has to sign in date
and time and then to get into the area
where the plants are that's a whole
another set of security people have to
put put on protective equipment
and there there there fobs on all of the
doors like and there are cameras
everywhere so if if DHHS wanted
to in great detail find out what we're
doing at 10:27 on Tuesday October 13th
they have a tremendous ability to do
that that I think is in excess of the
security measures you'd find probably at
any other business in New
Hampshire thank you any anyone else any
other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Bill
brigh from the New Hampshire State
Police name is Bill you could put the
microphone on
please uh as stated my name is Bill
bright I'm a major with the New
Hampshire State Police I oversee our
Investigative Services Bureau um I've
been assigned this bill um and it
looking at it from a law enforcement uh
perspective the thing that I look for
are ways that uh you know a new law
could be exploited um and one of the
things that I that I don't see in this
bill is that uh that this would be
limited to New Hampshire um alternative
treatment uh facilities I don't know uh
if that has been thought of or addressed
uh but I do know that if there's other
alternative treatment facilities from
other states also looking for additional
locations this could be a door for that
which would mean more of these locations
in our state that would not be uh
providing any product to um to our
residents that need it um that would be
one thing that I would be concerned of
and I do know that uh with lack of
regulation in uh other states
surrounding us they have struggled with
black market sales additional facilities
uh being used
for uh for for black market sales uh for
getting um they they've been purchasing
residential homes and using those um and
I know there's been a lot of talk about
the security and how that would be
regulated in this state but I I think
that some of that needs to be defined in
the language of a of a law so that those
things are not exploited um the way that
the potential is um at this time so um
those were the things that I saw with
this uh just wanted to provide that
perspective any
questions representative D just to be
clear major BR are you opposing the bill
yes sir
okay any other
questions seeing none okay thank you sir
thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on H B 301 does anyone else wish yes
representative coner did you have a
question
or
sure thank you microphone thank you for
the opportunity uh and this goes to
representative McKay's question and this
is um which was um does this is this is
this an expansion of the um the the
footprint or does this bring in new
operators um into the state to uh
cultivate and the answer is definitively
um this is these second cultivation
facilities are only for the existing
atc's alternative treatment centers is a
defined term in the rule there's no
possible way under this amendment or
this this bill and the structure of 126
at large um that an outside entity could
um you know Avail themselves of this law
to to expand their footprint here this
is only atcs it's def term in the law so
I just want to clarify that open
question that you raised
um thank you very much thanks for the
clarification
yeah okay again no one else has signed
up to testify on hb31 does anyone else
wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on
hb31 uh we have about five minutes
before we will hear our final bill of
the day which is HB
I'm going to head
yeah
e
e e
okay it is uh 145 actually it's about
147 and I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB 54 FN and recognize the
prime sponsor who is no stranger to this
committee representative Wendy
Thomas hi everyone um for the oh thank
you Mr chair and members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Wendy Thomas and I just want to let you
know that I am going to be um
introducing another bill on another
Topic in another committee at 2 o'clock
so I may have to testify and then run
but there's others that are going to
testify that will take up the cause um
uh again my name is Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac I'm here to
introduce HB 54 which is an act allowing
alternative treatment centers to operate
for profit from a policy perspective
this bill is pretty simple if HB 54
becomes law HTC's could convert from
their current nonprofit structure and
become either a domestic business
Corporation or limited liability
corporation uh a company their plan of
conversion would be subject to approval
by their nonprofit board of directors
the purpose of HB 54 is to enable atcs
to operate and Access Capital more like
traditional businesses which should
result in them being able to offer lower
prices and provide better services for
patients I believe representatives from
the atcs are here and they can speak
much better than I can to the specific
challenges and costs that have been
associated with the require that they be
organized as
nonprofits despite not being recognized
as non nonprofits by the
IRS this issue before us today is not
new in fact the House and Senate have
passed similar legislation with strong
bipartisan support on multiple occasions
and two previous bills on this subject
have come very close to becoming law in
2019 the House and Senate passed Senate
Bill 145 but it was vetoed by the
governor the override effort fell one
vote short in the senate in
202022 the house and the Senate passed a
SB 38 but it was once again vetoed by
the governor the Senate voted 19 to5 to
override The veto but the effort fell
short one vote in the
house additionally many other states
initially required nonprofit status for
medical cannabis businesses but nearly
all have removed this requirement
including our three neighboring states
Vermont included a nonprofit requirement
when it added dispensaries to its
medical cannabis law in
2011 this requirement was eliminated in
2017 Maine started off as nonprofit in
2009 and it was eliminated in
2018 Massachusetts started as nonprofit
in 2012 and the requirement was
eliminated in
2017 this is important because
neighboring states are currently serving
served by hundreds of for-profit
cannabis businesses which are competing
to serve patients and adult consumers
including residents of New Hampshire if
we want our atcs to be set up for
success in this regional market and if
we want to keep our New Hampshire
patients shopping here at the
dispensaries in our state we need to
make this change so that we can at least
somewhat level the playing field um and
lastly I would just like to make the
point that uh I have received received
uh feedback on this bill and there there
seems to be a little bit of confusion
going from nonprofit to for-profit does
not mean you have to price G gouge your
product and make as much profit as
possible it means it's a different
marketing strategy and it enables you to
have different kind of financing and
funding I'm happy to take any questions
thank you what did you say the previous
bills that had got had been vetoed what
their numbers were uh sure um in 2019 it
was was SB 145 and SB 145 okay and in
2022 it was
sb38 38
sb38 great thank you you're welcome any
other
questions representative n thank you for
T um Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so nothing would change about
the funding mandate that the system
would still have to be self-sufficient
but would dramatically increase the
options that the centers would have for
funding themselves is that correct yes
yes other representative
Lamonte thank you and thank you for
taking my question can you think of any
other medical practices or services or
pharmacies that are required to be
nonprofit I don't know if I'm the
definitive answer on this but
no okay
thanks other
questions seeing n okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Sue homo
from Sam New
Hampshire I'm still mispronouncing your
name aren't I oh that's okay that's fine
by
me so thank you again um Sue hola Sam
New Hampshire um I I Rec recognize that
I may appear to many today as Dr no just
no and I'm I'm not trying to be Dr no
but I I am trying to bring up
information that needs to be considered
because oftentimes legislation gets
passed and the unintended consequences
do not get considered when the medical
marijuana program was enacted it was
with the intention that the atcs have
nonprofit restrictions for a variety of
reasons and one of them was to ensure
that our citizens to ensure uh our
citizens that um that marijuana
nonprofit influence did not flood into
our
state our current atcs must operate
within the confines of nonprofit for
this for this reason the fact that they
can't take advantage of a tax benefit
from being a nonprofit because they are
selling a federally illegal schedule one
drug is the conundrum of our state's own
making and exactly what the state signed
on for when we created the therapeutic
cannabis program this was the trade-off
to ensure that New Hampshire keep some
sort of lid on the negative effects of
what happens in other states and what
has happened in other states when the
marijuana Lobby dollars get in bedw
State House policy in a for-profit
environment those who invest in a
medical marijuana business expect
Financial growth in return they expect
it if a respon if the responsible Public
Safety safeguards and compassionate care
for medical marijuana users is the
actual goal of legislators and our
therapeutic cannabis board then it will
ensure that atc's remain nonprofit um
one of the things that one of the
questions that uh rep I'm sorry I don't
know how to say your name you had a
question about what other medical places
are for-profit and what are nonprofit
required to be nonprofit I'm not sure if
anyone I mean all we have to do is step
back and look what are some of the
issues that people are actually having
with the today's current US Health Care
System the for-profit at some one time
they're villains and then with medical
marijuana they're not villains you know
I'm not I'm not calling anyone a villain
or not I'm just saying that we have
healthc care companies for profit seem
to be a problem some of the hospitals
Hospital administrations when they go
nonpr when they go for-profit seem to be
a problem I I just there's a hypocrisy
to to the conversations we have about
for-profit nonprofit We intentionally
made the state of New Hampshire's uh
medical marijuana program to be such as
to keep a lid on some of these negative
consequen es has happened even though I
understand the issues we have with Maine
and Massachusetts and Vermont but
actually if you look a little closer to
those I mean those things are going off
the rails and that's that's all I have
to
say thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Mike
mclin from Sanctuary ATC
good afternoon again Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Mike
glofin I represent Sanctuary TC I uh had
forwarded to the committee uh
electronically a u memo on the um this
bill I call this bill my full employment
bill because I've been working on it
since
2019 uh and the history of the bill is
that the House and Senate have passed
this bill every time it's come before
them and the reason they passed this
bill is is because again the number one
complaint of therapeutic cannabis
patients is price the not for-profits um
designation of the atc's if you look
back in the history of why and how the
bill was passed it's hard to find the
reason it's almost like having a car and
having to walk around it three times
before you can get in started there's no
benefit for the not for-profit status to
the uh atc's or to the patients there's
no exemption of property tax there's no
exemption on anything that a for-profit
corporation gets in Hampshire is
unavailable to the atcs all it does is
ADD cost and it adds um inability to
raise Capital they can't sell stock uh
they can't the only reason they get way
they get money is through grants which
it can't get from it even nobody gives a
grant so if you if you think back you
know in a historical perspective the
2019 2020 2022 legislators all said this
is a good idea the um it's interesting
if you look at the The veto override I
think it was Senate Bill 38 where the
Senate voted 19 to5 to override The veto
the house veto is was actually house
over was actually one of those
mathematical um U anomalies where it's
2/3 and not 66% because if you look at
the numbers I gave you I think I laid it
out that it came out to be I think 65.99
n% or whatever it was where they missed
by one thousand of a percent to be 2/3
so it is not a novel idea it's something
that we've looked at for almost six
years and said what benefit is anybody
getting the patients get no benefit the
states get no benefit the only thing it
does is create this uh artificial uh not
for-profit it's not a not for-profit uh
they make money uh if they are turned
into a for-profit we had had projections
several years ago the price would drop
10% because the cost of capital when you
lend money to a u a company or you sell
stock the expectation is to make profit
but you don't have to pay it back right
it's an investment so there are no
Investments they have been lucky enough
in Hampshire to have operators who have
had enough money to be able to create
the businesses but this is won't expand
anything it's been a it's not a novel
idea uh I've given you the history of it
it's um uh it will do no harm it will
only create an opportunity to lower the
prices and improve the the whole
operations
Qui uh representative
Weber thank you very much and and my
apologies I'm a little behind on my bill
reading so I haven't actually gone all
the way through this one um could you
explain to me if there is anything I and
I think that the concern that people
have with thinking oh not uh for-profit
corporations stock shareholders Prof
profets um profits that get to go
outside of the
entity are
there parts of this
legislation as proposed today that inure
that that's not going to happen or I and
I I think that the people who are
opposed have a real issue in their heads
and about oh my gosh you know this is
suddenly going to become a prophet
center that is going to allow profit to
be taken out of the business and
therefore it may not lower costs and um
I understand that that's not the intent
currently but I want to know is there
anything in here that prevents that from
happening well in the in the body of the
bill which uh has been in the body of
the bill for the last six years is a
Prohibition against selling uh to
outstate foreign corporations so if an
ATC in New Hampshire is going to raise
money via selling the stock they
Incorporated themselves they would not
be able to sell um shares to outside
foreign corporations so foreign
corporation meaning simply a corporation
is not registered within the in
Hampshire um
it's I think if the bill came in and
said can we operate as a normal business
there would be less issue because you
see the word for-profit there's a lot of
for-profit companies that lose money I
just quite understood it's just a
designation that says I can operate as a
normal business I don't have to create
uh some mythical management structure
that doesn't you know is getting
compensated as opposed to a regular
Corporation it's a um uh and again the
price issue if you have the opportunity
to do more business by lowering your
price that's what you're going to do and
right now the biggest complaint is
patients say I can't afford it so if you
can get your two or four ounces but the
next week you've got no money left so
the idea is as Matt said earlier Grant
Leaf has ability to grow more product
but they can't sell it because it's very
uh cost it's it's expensive and so uh
there's no nefarious idea here to create
um an outstate marijuana giant buying in
we don't do enough business to to you
know create any great interest from out
ofate Mega marijuana and I think as a um
a thought that is pervasive today the
marijuana Golden Goose has shrunk
dramatically uh prices have dropped over
the country dramatically so the thought
of a Canada Cannabis or one of the big
companies saying oh man I can get into
hisory well they couldn't get in anyway
for 3 years Max minimum but there's no
um dramatic profit available we only
have 13,000 patients so it's it's
something that I wish the bill said can
we operate as a normal
business thank
you representative
Nel thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I think it's
wonderful that as imperfect as our
system is in New Hampshire and I having
been involved with it since the
beginning I understand why it was
created the way it is but as imperfect
as it
is I'm concerned about the long-term
viability if the current system change
stays the same in other words the way
the nonprofit element I mean can you
give me a crystal ball and tell me can
you guys stay in business going forward
if we don't make changes like this no
you'll continue to have a program that
can't achieve its ultimate um
productivity or its ultimate goals uh
and and it is a a dramatic hamstring to
uh not be able to go out and find uh a
capital investor uh because a capital
investor is going to say okay I'm going
to wait for my return and see how it
goes and again uh we're under capacity
and a lot of people don't go ahead
followup followup are you in danger
going belly up I can only speak for our
guys and we are in Plymouth and in
Congress
Conway would get eaten alive across the
border in um
fryberg so you can have medical
marijuana patients in New Hampshire who
get their card uh go to a clinic for a
while and then they start searching for
an alternative and you go to Maine
you're going to get some products that
haven't been tested uh you got no idea
what you're getting at some point this
time so would they go a belly up I
couldn't say that today but I can say
one thing uh they're not going to look
for expanding Conway uh until they get
an opportunity to be able to compete
same thing with the Tasco which is in
Dover I mean they're close to me we've
got clinics close to
Massachusetts if everybody in the
business was not for-profit it would be
equal playing field that we have the
only not for-profit medical marijuana
system in the country I guess there's
one still in Arizona but the um it's
just like again it's been a long time
coming the legislators have always
agreed let's let us go where it's going
and not and go get the profit system
going but and again if it's if it's a
becomes a total uh cash grab I mean uh
the department of HHS can come in and
say let's put it back but right now they
not these guys aren't
thriving thank you representative
Weber so that leads me to another
question which is um they're not
thriving there's a very limited market
in New
Hampshire uh which is
there's excess capacity which is not
being utilized or excess space maybe not
excess capacity
so how is it that an investor is going
to rush into to invest in this business
because surely they want their money
back and they want to make a profit of
some kind which is not unreasonable the
only thing I'm concerned about going
forward is unreasonable profits but
I'm hearing two different narratives
here and I wonder if you can justify
those to me well let me give you the
first narrative um atcx I need
$100,000 I can't sell stocks so I
borrowed from Mr Smith he wants
8% my investor says I don't want 8% I
want to participate in the profits of
the business as it goes so when you're
stuck only being able to borrow money uh
your cost of operations are dramatically
impacted so to be ble to go for a
for-profit I had I could have get an
investor versus a a um a loan the loan
is always going to cost you more money
and the way interest rates out today
it's probably going to be eight or n%
plus the fact you can't borrow from a
bank so you're going to have to go to a
private investor that might be 15% and
and so that there's no abilities to get
Capital at a reasonable cost meaning
capital I give you $100,000 I say okay
next year what do we have to split up as
opposed to every month I about 6,000
bucks so it's a um the the neg negative
the hamstring of a business by not
having the ability to get capital is
what kills it and again should they
become I I I don't have the crystal ball
but the
untapped um capabilities are because
they don't have the money to do
it other
questions representative Nel thank you
Mr chairman as a followup to the
followup to the followup
um I'm I'm all my patients go to Main
and Massachusetts so my question is is
do we really have a limited market or is
it artificially limited because of the
price here I'm with you on that
completely if we had a for-profit system
and a price that was attractive would
create there'd be more people I mean
just like I represent Bingo clients and
if people go looking for the big jackpot
in this business they go looking for the
best price again the therapeutic
cannabis products that you can offer are
limited by the amount of money you can
spend because you'll say I've got 12
products eight sell good four don't you
don't get rid of the four because I
can't afford to keep producing them so
your your product offerings are going to
suffer because of your lack of
investment
Capital again I would only say look at
the note I put together which gives the
history again this is um obviously I'm
advocate for it but it's it's not an
earthshaking idea can we operate as a
normal domestic Corporation or normal
domestic LLC I don't see I I think
that's the answer the answer is yes to
that and it has been for the last six
years other
questions thank you so much Mr chairman
members of the committee okay thank
you also signed up to testify as Matt
Simon from Granite Leaf cannabis
thank you Mr chairman one last time for
the record Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis and we do support the
bill I'm not a business guy I've worked
for nonprofits in the advocacy space for
the last 18
years um I've been working for granite
leaf for the last three and a half years
so I've got a taste in that time over
what a lot of this law and the rules has
meant on the ground uh but going back to
2009 to 2013 I was advocating for the
medical canvas law which included this
nonprofit requirement why did we include
the nonprofit requirement I think it's
worth spending just a minute to answer
that the goals of that bill first and
foremost it was to protect patients from
arrest because cannabis possession was
still a crime crime in New
Hampshire we would have done as
advocates anything and compromised just
about any other aspect of the policy to
get patients their cards so they could
be protected from arrests that was by
far the most important thing to people
who were testifying in this committee I
think it was the most important thing to
the members of the committee back
then the other aspect was establishing
safe legal access to cannabis which we
attempted to do through hom grow and a
couple of bills those were rejected Bill
we ultimately ended up passing kept hom
grow a crime and created these nonprofit
dispensaries at the same time we were
advocating for protecting patients from
arrest and safe legal access our
opponents were fixated mostly on one
talking point and it was this isn't
actually about helping patients this is
an effort to create the next big
marijuana or the next big tobacco that
was the tagline of an organization
you've actually heard from their instate
affiliate a few times today project Sam
is the name of the National Organization
and they popularize this talking point
it's about creating the next big tobacco
it's not about helping sick people so
long story short it passed
and we were all going to see how it
worked out and now we've seen how it
worked out it's worked out very
expensively for the atc's and for the
patients of New Hampshire and state by
state there were I found 10 states that
had required nonprofit status initially
Arizona is the only one I can find that
still has it on the books and they've
created a workaround so basically the
states all realized that this was
costing the companies more that were
trying to provide access to patients and
one by one they eliminated those
requirements
um want to also comment on the the loan
issue because what we have found and I
have this from our our CEO if you want
to get into the Weeds on these things we
would be happy to talk to you for hours
really as much detail as you want but
I'm trying to keep it as high level as
possible it's hard to get a loan too
it's not just Capital when we go to get
a loan they want collateral for the loan
we don't own anything we're a nonprofit
so that right
there even the loans we can get if we
can get them are at exorbitant ratees
this is just something that is added
costs at every level of the business
from startup to present it continues to
add costs and it will continue to add
costs uh until it's changed if
nonprofits are the best way to make
important goods available affordably to
the population I'd suggest that we would
have nonprofit grocery stores we would
have nonprofit box stores we would have
nonprofit manufacturing companies and
instead we we feel like a unicorn like
we're a company that manufactures and
sells products but we're not allowed to
operate like a normal business and we
have to find a workaround for literally
everything and all of those workarounds
are expensive so I'll stop there happy
to get in the weeds if you like thank
you any
questions seeing none thank you sir
thank you thank the committee
no one else has signed up to testify on
HB 54 FN does anyone wish to
testify if not I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB 54 FN that
concludes the hearings for today we will
be back here tomorrow morning with more
hearings to more bills to be heard uh
have a good evening everybody and uh we
stand
adjourned
e e